[Applause]
oh man
big energy
we got a fan we got our very own fan
girl here dan thank you dan love that
energy go
left go
today is july 8th boy how time goes by
friday baby friday
no sponsors today
epic
[Music]
[Laughter]
um
excuse me it's been two weeks since i've
covered guys i'm fine
two weeks since my fever broke
i'm fine
but i'll say this um
your mask is making me uncomfortable
okay i already took it off tucker leave
me alone
we do have one sponsor by beautiful
anime gila
you look like a one-piece character with
your braids thank you
so how does this work this isn't your
hair
in your hair
it's my hair plus
plus
really it looks so nice and such a good
match on the color yeah right
yeah
it's um it's like extensions that kind
of like clip on so i can just take it
off after this but you styled this
i see i see that's why
not me but yeah
who did it
my hair and jess oh you had a hair girl
do this yeah okay wow
wow what a vibe
okay interesting well there you go
sponsoring this episode
teddyfresh.com
go to teddyfridge.com to celebrate hey
gabe one sec there buddy
um to celebrate our collaboration with
one of ula's favorite artist gentle
thrills
that's what i'm wearing
check this out
should we check
this game frozen or is he just super
happy
what's up how you doing you want to do
this now
friday baby
it's friday [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
[Applause]
have you had covert gabe
covered twice but i recovered i heard
you got covered last week but i'm glad
you're feeling better thanks bro
churchill great recovery
[ __ ] yeah thank you bro you had coveted
twice damned
did you did it hit you pretty hard or
where did you get over it pretty good
easy mild system it's kind of like i'm
having a cold that's about it like a
common cold because you're a you're like
a stallion dude the virus like that
couldn't slow you down huh
oh yeah yeah you know what's the simple
solution to a covet
what's that
oh
is that
okay my medicine
baby chug it down all right
oh
kill cover 19.
[Music]
no no no that's not wait wait wait wait
wait we need to be clear that's not
alcohol we can get in trouble
that's not alcohol
that's water just
tell us
that's water right because we'll get in
trouble for showing that
you weren't drinking
yeah
the covet germs are dying you might have
had it a third time but they all just
got eradicated
oh yeah i probably won't even notice
yeah if you noticed and you got positive
oh well please [ __ ] yeah
yo gabe you got a fresh cut what's going
on with the hair you look good
um haircut last week
nice let me see let me show me off the
sides and stuff that's a fresh fade bro
[Music]
fade damn did you order that fade or did
they just kind of hit you with it
i tell them and i they do it no that's
my personal opinion that was your order
that was your [ __ ]
oh
man what are you doing this weekend
anything fun
well i'm headed to the script strip club
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you're gonna get a private lap dance or
are you just gonna kind of
you
know like a happy ending kind of thing
you know
happy lapdown
oh [ __ ] do you ever
can i ask you a question have you ever
[ __ ] in your pants or anything like
that at the strip club
um sometimes
there it is
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] that's what i'm talking
about and when you juice in your pants
is that part of like the lap dance or
you just is it from like it's it's
normal i'd say it's normal yeah
yeah yeah it's just um
it's just like you know letting it out
right is it from her grinding on you or
just general excitement okay
it's kind of like
it's kind of like venting you let you
let your get your emotions back yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've done that
what did i do wrong i'm telling zach the
music's too much
the music's just right
yes baby we got a good ass time planned
for this weekend boy dan's gonna come
is there a certain girl you like at that
spot or you kind of just
find someone that looks pretty
that's nice nice and understanding and
pretty of course
[Music]
what's your type what do you look for
when you go to you're when you're
looking for that
that special uh champagne room dance or
whatever
it's in or brunette kind of thing you
said asian or brunette
yeah hell yeah
oh yeah
and like are what are you more
interested in ass or breasts
come on the ass baby
you like it like tight or like just big
i prefer it tight because it's small and
yeah
right right right right i like legs uh
ass legs are good too it's just it's
connected to the ass
right that's right it's all covered
connected to the anatomy lesson for
everyone at home never thought about it
like that one whole kind of thing you
can't separate
do you ever i've we've talked we
interviewed a stripper recently and we
got some mixed info from her that maybe
but you're not allowed to touch right
during the lap dance right
well it depends if you go to like miami
vegas
probably you would probably don't let
you but if you go to least like tight
places there are really like
how was hollywood like the body shop
they're stiffs you can't touch no
touching right she got a man
you have to go to like miami or vegas
then you can they can feel like things
oh yeah they'll make you touch
they force me to touch them oh damn they
put your hands right on them huh yeah
[ __ ]
wow
wow that's amazing man that's really
interesting stuff it's beautiful
yeah
that i don't touch they forced me no i
know i believe you i i got that man
that's crazy
wow
and so well i hope you have a good time
okay don't get into trouble out there
you know don't get kicked out or
anything okay gabe
all right yeah yeah the good one and ooh
best recovery thank you
you're feeling better
how much does it cost for a private how
much does it cost for a private dance
i'd say
200 to 300. whoa damn that's a lot of
cameos boy
it's worth it though
yeah it sounds like it sounds like it's
a good time
you're gonna put her kids through
college you get a little you get to
cream in your pants a little bit
respectfully
yeah
all right you have fun that sounds great
man
appreciate you buddy love you okay you
take care of me
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that's how we used to do it it was super
aggressive i play that sound bites out
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
sounds like
my man anyway back to uh we were in the
middle of a ad read
teddyfresh.com
uh gentle thrills
check out this shirt here show this you
got on one side good bears go to heaven
bad bears go everywhere
everywhere
[Laughter]
you're sure
show off that whole fit
that fit goes hard
she made these
she made those pants
and i picked those
af dude
and av's rocking the camp shirt looking
very good yeah a few of us are oh really
how many camp shirts we got now zach
what's up baby
let's go
zach's got that button down pretty low
let me take this dv baby wait how deep
are you going
wait how many buttons is that uh two
two that's just two that looks more than
two that's three yeah three
three exactly did you call it a dvd
yeah is like a
like a domestic violence no like a
v-neck yeah i thought like guys that
wear shirts like that are usually
what the [ __ ] they have to give
a tv it's a dvd
i didn't get the arab jeans when it came
to my chest you're hairless bro
my ass too
wow lucky holy smokes
your butthole's got hair on it right
they got attached
[Laughter]
you're not that low no no i gotta say i
i [ __ ] love this shirt so much
the material is like insane like it it
perfect fit on me yeah
there it is thank you jack also cam is
wearing um
the embroidered teeth good bears go to
heaven check it out cam looks great in
it
i believe some of the girls have
of the ladies
showed off sam yeah let's get it looking
good oh lena in the um in the tank
beautiful
everyone looks amazing
and dan what are you wearing
i'm wearing a teddy fresh release from
about four years that's actually true
yeah that's a good either
that's a goodie well anyways guys if you
want to support
the show uh ela
whatever go to teddyfest.com check out
some of these cool
items here thank you so much
looking good everyone
thank you all right so we have so we
actually have a lot to do today all of
our trees calling in at 1pm
we got to talk about elon musk we got to
talk about
um wendy williams we got to talk about
another keemstar meme
of massive keemstar fail oh yeah
potentially on the scale of the aidan
rossville
it's up there it's up it's up there it's
pretty good and then there's the bonus
with him too uh giving his foreign
policy analysis right which is maybe
this may have rocketed up to my favorite
keemstar video real time
it's a contender for sure okay so so
that's all exciting stuff you guys have
been dying for me to do the sprite
challenge by the way please everybody
maybe what's that you have to try to
chug a whole bottle of sprite without
burping oh god
but actually lina lina did you do it did
you achieve it i did well no i don't
think i finished but baby did it no no
we attempted it but she she made it
longer than me but she didn't finish
yeah i was gonna say i don't i wouldn't
have advised it for you guys if you're
already not feeling well don't run the
don't know the fun okay
thanks thanks for caring nina i'm gonna
try it though but i appreciate it
why did you feel really bad afterwards
my stomach was hurting yeah oh i am i
had to keep like burping it out that
sounds yeah well thank you i like that
yeah you don't have to try it either i
wouldn't make you do that not doing that
um
so we've got that we'll do that after um
oliver okay so we don't forget it
and uh actually a lot more really
interesting stuff
so is oliver ready to call in uh he
should be calling in any second let me
uh so why are we talking to oliver today
well we uh oh i'm checking my messages
right now let's see all of her
oliver white well they're running ten
minutes like this [ __ ] loser
[ __ ] my time means nothing to him
idiot
why are we talking to oliver today he
got in a a fight on stage tmz reported
on it
um
but most importantly it was his birthday
last week
oh god yeah so so me and oliver actually
have our birthdays are like three days
apart and so i got a
pinata of oliver which you saw me break
apart right
and so oliver got a pinata of ethan
so he's he want he wanted to call in and
get revenge and be like
yo you smashed this pinata
of me i'm gonna smash this me out of you
he's a petty little [ __ ] loser all
right and he's just always gotta have
some [ __ ] to say so he's to call in and
do that
okay idiot loser
until then i guess let's see top of the
show stuff do you want me to do the
sprite challenge
you're going to be
struggling
hey i want to talk about something
this was huge news on the subreddit and
hila i'm curious what's your take on it
everybody's talking about this moment
from the dan um collective of last
episode zach apparently bodied cam out
of frame
now what i need to see here
is the full shot because this could be
maybe a little misleading
you know what i mean it did look like he
elbowed him out though for sure
[Laughter]
yeah but this had 2 500 points
lots of controversy can someone find me
the time yeah i'm almost yeah yeah
because i want to see what the full
context here
now
before i ask you about this zak let me
ask cameron
did you notice this happening uh when it
happened
oh we got it not at all not at all okay
no
i couldn't believe
i mean beside besides like the uh
the post i couldn't believe the comments
that that was getting exactly was
getting a lot of heat
yeah people's people tend to give zach a
lot of [ __ ] yeah i mean it's kind of
like
if i may speak ethan it's kind of
uncalled for and some of the [ __ ] on
there yes there's jokes
but some of the [ __ ] on there is really
like just
so uncalled for really and i just want
to say i'm a person okay i
i yes i'm i'm on the show but i'm also
zach i'm a person too
and people just i think fail to realize
that
no matter what you type it
it's going to affect you okay
people people were saying that i need to
go check get checked out for autism
yeah it's like
people don't
it's just it really totally [ __ ] up my
morning tremendously yeah i feel that it
feels bad man people say you mean things
about you on the internet feels bad and
like
if you want to defend me don't
put down my friend man thank you cam and
i have a i didn't i would never like go
out of my way to just elbow camp cam and
i have a great relationship we have a
great friendship
and
it's like you know
i don't know what else to say on it
i will get [ __ ] no matter what just
because i am me okay and i try and do
the best job i can
but some people don't view it that way
does this make you feel better i saw
comments like man it sucks he's so good
at doing the sounds
there was a there was an element
well it's kind of a good compliment too
because yeah it's like even your biggest
haters still acknowledging right job
yeah biggest haters can't deny that
you're the sound man right well
to be the change i want to see in the
world right now i'm making a zack
appreciation post on the subreddit right
now oh wow i hope that surpasses uh
i hope that surpasses i will make change
i want to my life
i'm gonna feel a little kid's dick in my
butthole i'm gonna make it right
sorry it's hard enough to remix these
songs
[Music]
sorry zack i
you're good i love playing because i'm
jason
anyways it i'm gonna make a chance
anyway sorry uh zack i get it man it
hurts let's watch the let's watch the
clip and let's see if it's taken out of
context here we go behold the chamber
up there everyone's kind of sitting
together we give honor and and then cam
well cam finds a standpoint
the wizard
they get kind of muscled
[Laughter]
so
dan based on the laughter did it not
help i feel like the full context didn't
particularly
elbow him
let's watch that one more time today cam
seems pretty comfortable that this is
pretty that's like a trump move i feel
like i've seen trump do that zach
i gotta say this with all the peace and
the love and my heart and everything big
boys go in the back for four i i was
i i'm so upset about all the hate he's
getting but i try to protect him from
this i told him he's the tallest he
needs to be in back right always telling
him this
trying to prevent this zach
so they're trying to get in the shot
they're saying it's your fault the
hatred is
yeah but it's just funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah people like reading into it
just like a mistake yeah right i mean i
to be honest i kind of wanted to get
away from ethan
um oh is that what was going on yeah but
let's try to analyze it with that until
because if i went behind eb i felt like
i would have been so you're sacrificing
so you said cam you go be close i
wouldn't
one of the comments mean comments i saw
said that you're the george costanza of
the podcast right like how he throws the
kids out of the way to the grandmother
or whatever yeah that doesn't kind of
have that that is kind of a you know
what with that new intel zak do you
accept the george costanza analogy at
all yeah i'll take it
i mean george is a legend yeah i mean
based on larry david because you kind of
threw cam into the fire i did no i could
have easily stood up too i was just
i didn't even think twice about it i
could there's plenty of space
for me there too it's all good there's
like this this was funny yes i
understand that but there's so much
unwarranted hate it just does not be
that way i get it some people don't like
me that's how it goes but don't say i'm
like [ __ ] autistic or needed to get
bullied as a like i i i was a bully as a
kid like you don't know what i've
[ __ ] been through oh that you were a
bully yeah who's the bully you're trying
to attack this guy off of a little clip
of him and his close friend who he sees
every day right so when these people sit
behind their computer and think there's
nothing going into it you know it it
affects people it really does so that's
all i have to say on it it just bugged
me that's all i'm gonna do one thing i
want to say is first of all
this is not there's nothing serious ever
happening here guys you should know that
but reading the thread zach i think
and this goes for everybody you know
i've we've been on the receiving end of
[ __ ] comments and where people are
overly judgmental and drawing
conclusions and
it's never easy but
it takes i think it takes some
discipline and practice before you not
take it like totally personally right
but i do think that that maybe
as
as harsh as it feels in the comments
people probably aren't hating you as
much as it feels like too i mean because
people do they just they talk like
you're not reading you know that's what
i always say right talk about they're
it's like you know how you talk about
someone when they're not there you you
be more
you lay it on thicker or harsher than
you would if they were listening right
and i know there's a lot of love i know
there's a lot of love we have a great
audience and i love them
um but there's you know those bad apples
in the bunch that are just
i don't know they don't know me i guess
as a person
they just think i'm just gonna [ __ ] talk
this person just because and um it's
hurtful but i guess that's the nature of
the game of being you know on the
internet
there it is it does it really sucks and
um
i mean i don't know if i need to um
say it but zach is like the sweetest guy
ever so that's the real irony people
saying that he's a bully zack is
definitely the nicest person in this
room
thank like the type of guy kind of guy
to defend me from bullies you know yeah
and also i just think people need to
keep in mind that like
you
zack you kind of like show your
personality you're really bold you tell
stories you're not afraid of like
maybe saying something stupid or you
know whatever it's gonna be but it makes
the show a better show
and that's part of just putting yourself
out there exactly and so it sucks to
think that
because of that
it might cause you to go the other way
and not
not be as involved in the show because
people
take it too far right so i think for the
audience like try to keep that in mind
is is just doing like
he's actually entertaining you guys and
making the show better by putting
himself out there so
like try not to be mean about it but i
know it's easy to say and hard to do all
right but here it is just one more time
guys we could put it in slow motion
just to get one full analysis before we
move on
let's see here uh quarter speed what do
you think
maybe too slow
here comes the moment of crisis okay
here it is back now the incident now cam
seems pretty trenched in there he seems
comfortable he seems very happy he seems
like that's a good spot for him
and then and then you did throw the
elbow first i was putting my arm on the
table because i was trying to frame up
with the tv okay so it wasn't an elbow
thrown at cam you were absolutely
knocking yourself on the table i would
never elbow cam and i apologize cam sure
but you have you have nothing to
apologize for okay
what's interesting is cam didn't even
noticing it happen i think that says it
all but what we have here is
cam has been um submerged in a sea of
dance he could have stayed right there
are you gonna force closer to the um
to the center of chernobyl
i think i realized that there was more
people on the way too so i moved down as
much as i could
to make room for the other folks coming
in
interesting in defense of zach and i
seen a comment say this as well he's a
tall boy he's very tall and one of the
people
protecting you were saying that they
dated a tall guy and they have no
spatial awareness i will say funny zack
is very tall and sometimes he just steps
on [ __ ] and doesn't realize because he's
well now you're treating me like lenny
from a mice and men
well that's not well yeah
all right tell me about this
tell me about the rabbits and i'll tell
you what buddy i'm just not [ __ ]
bullied
if you don't get your [ __ ] together i'm
gonna have to take your ass in back zach
tell me tell me about the fire one in
the back of the tell me about the
rabbits ethan tell me about the rock
i'll tell you all about the rabbits
but one more time guys so he grabs the
chair
can we start it to cam smiling because
that's where
that's that's part look at that
beautiful cam smile but how do we end up
what's the final uh
it zooms out there's enough room for
everybody
okay cam really took a dive
right behind it
and it's unfortunate that something as
beautiful as the dan appreciation has
turned into this we love dan but i do
want to say guys i want to say i don't i
think the majority of the thread isn't
that serious i think the person who
posted probably was just goofing around
right and then obviously some people
take it too far and they and they read
too far into things but
uh you know we love zach
in fact i bet if we took a poll it'd be
95 percent we love zach well thank you
you want to do that let's do a poll you
don't have to
yeah let's do something yes no i don't
know i
no do the pull i'm confident i have that
much confidence what's the question do
you love zach do you love zach yes or no
yeah
most of the people who watch the show
don't comment
do you want to ruin that weekend no no
no no this is this is gonna turn out ab
what do you mean bruin how what are you
talking about this is gonna turn out big
for zach
everybody don't worry buddy only like 15
of people
well if you did if you did do you love
ethan i mean what do you think it would
be probably not that it probably
wouldn't be 100 either you know what i'm
saying whoa
so here we go ninety percent
wait i gotta i gotta vote i gotta vote
you vote no tell me about that oh the
rabbit's
oh [ __ ] it's going down no i'm just
kidding okay i didn't get to vote i
wasn't didn't have the browser open but
yeah i mean 88 that's pretty good i'll
take it like if you take if you now
who's someone that's loved on this
podcast would you say
olivia i love you okay now dude do you
love olivia let's see what's the
let's see
so i'm just saying everyone has
detractors right 88 zack that's pretty
good right i'll take it dude hasn't even
asked for it that's pretty good crazy
that's very high man yeah
no i love it that's a super majority
yeah yeah
now olivia obviously i'm gonna vote yes
me too um let's see how much people love
olivia here
um
the numbers and
uh 92
they don't even like her that much more
than you straight up
how does it feel zach
olivia is queen we all know that zach is
queen now it's down to 90 zack she only
got two percentage points on you damn
dude that's what i'm saying it's all
love baby elections are fraud man
yeah and then you probably feel terrible
about that olivia only two percent more
than that yeah i'm i'm truly devastated
i have to i have to workshop i have to
go back to the drawing board
reinvent myself
reinventing anna
oh thank you oh sweet potatoes by the
way for 50 gifted subbies
100 total i think it yeah damn son let's
go potato boy
potato boy so there you go zack you feel
better i do right 88 no no that that's
beautiful
i really appreciate that you know 88 is
everything there it is
but yeah i just i'll love you all
um oliver is in the waiting room all
right let's get this idiot now dude not
here to do a poll do you like oliver
tree now you want to see someone that's
hated zach
do that you didn't even say love you
said like jesus
yeah well who loves him maybe zero
percent do you even like oliver tree
you know and obviously i'm gonna vote no
because i [ __ ] don't like him
okay so here we go do
do you like this [ __ ] idiot oliver
tree no
okay now the votes are coming in for
clown show oliver tree
sixty percent no that that's hate
this man is hated he's reviled yeah he
[ __ ] sucks dude
speaking witch
hey idiot
we just did a poll and we said do you
like oliver tree 60 said no dude idiot
[Music]
oh what is he doing a ringo starr he
looks like he's about to peace and love
us
excuse me i can hear you
you can hear me now after i wait two
[ __ ] hours shut up dude you were
scheduled at one you're 20 minutes late
by time that was nothing how was your
shower oliver
shut the [ __ ] up hey oliver you're like
a director right you say oh i direct my
own movies like you fancy yourself
yeah you fancy yourself a filmmaker
why the [ __ ] are you shooting into a
bright window you moan
could you shut the [ __ ] up literally 101
dude
no more [ __ ] laugh track stop with
the [ __ ] bells and whistles
[Music]
i did get new glasses you know why
because you [ __ ] broke my other ones
my clothes are fake now all i have is
these shitty ones yeah don't bring it up
i still want my [ __ ] money for that
[ __ ] dude you gotta pay me back and the
[ __ ] check you sent bounce yeah i'll
send you 150 for the alibaba order
i think it was i was the one that broke
them right no i cracked them oh it was
you yeah yeah you cracked you for no
reason because you're a cry baby and
you're a mama's boy
hey um
nice sweat hoodie though i'm not going
to hate on that
well if you want to know who's the only
thing i had that was clean because
things have been rough yeah it's been
traveling with my suitcases and this was
the only clean thing and i honestly
wanted to [ __ ] burn it but i didn't
have time to do it when i was last at
the beach on a bonfire right
with your books and everything you're
because you're a freaking your book
you've been what you've heard books like
a [ __ ] nazi all right dude
that's too [ __ ] far but what are you
inviting me on here to [ __ ] make fun
of me well it was your birthday right
that's why we're calling in
well it was technically our birthday
yeah our birthdays are three days apart
which i don't i'm not happy about that
to be clear but it is what it is
and you what you turned 39 or something
i turned 19.
yeah you can't even say that [ __ ] with a
straight face
i turn 19 it's not funny i'm just sad
because i'm getting older
yeah it is it is sad kind of in there
almost out of your teens um how old did
you turn
37 dude oh god
i feel bad for you
yeah
so what you want to just invite me on
here to ready to kill me in front of
your 10 fans watching all right so well
there's a few things i wanted to talk
about and then we could
you have a pinata of mia as i understand
it
i don't know anything about that
what didn't we send you a pinata of me
well it was his uh you know his little
weirdo minions that collected my
pitching paul has it oh
hey you leave high-pitched paul out of
there no he has the pinata he has it
no
i don't know anything about pinata uh
okay
all right well all right well see you
later bro that was the whole point wait
wait wait
it may or may not be a pinata okay
all right but before we get to the
pinata [ __ ]
i want to talk about a couple of things
as always you're always getting some
dumbass drama
oh yeah very funny says the [ __ ] 52
year old man is getting in drama every
day very funny
oliver tree beats up a fan on stage tmz
can you believe they wrote this about
your fake ass fight
it's not [ __ ] fake there's nothing
fake about that that was a real fight
that guy had no business being on the
stage
let me take you guys you can't even use
a [ __ ] computer you old ass man shut
up dude let me take a close look at this
oh that's so fake that guy how is that
fake this [ __ ] guy came on stage i
was trying to let him do his thing and
then look it this is where he crosses
the threshold oh he touched your hair
not on me okay
five hours of prosthetics right five
[ __ ] hours so at that moment
no
yes it did you know how long prosthetics
take have you ever done anything like
that oh no you haven't you've never done
anything with your life
wait this was at the nft convention bro
yes you were shilling nfts dude let's go
yeah i'm doing it hey i'm gonna send you
an nft of these nuts bro
all right
no ethan if you scroll down in the
article there's something interesting in
there interesting photo okay let me just
watch the yeah go ahead i have a
question
this is a real article yeah um tmz
actually wrote this [ __ ] pretty funny
right yeah
at the [ __ ] nft con yeah but let me
watch this [ __ ] okay nothing funny about
it okay they threw me out to die out
there they literally this was covered on
52 media outlets
so let's see he touches the hair oliver
gets him in the classic headlock brings
him down
and then what he's what you see here
those are yeah those are fake punches
all over those are not [ __ ] fake
punches
you should have seen him when i was done
with him he looked a little similar the
last time i fought you and destroyed you
he looks like he punches in a dream oh
yeah yeah yeah right there dan shut the
[ __ ] up
that's crazy how many people showed up
there like 75 that's nuts
it was literally a private event they
couldn't have any more people there
because the fire coordinator was there
and
everyone came out for you man look at
all that empty space here in the middle
none of those people were my fans this
was for a private event you could not
get into this if you wanted to for sure
i was only able to get one close friend
into the building for sure yeah look up
look at look at the railing up top look
at all those empty spots bro it's
literally a private event where they pay
me an absurd amount of cash okay how
much they pay you for that i'm not going
to tell you but way more let's just say
this did they pay you in nfts or usd
everything you made last year
times 10. did they pay you in usd or nft
bro i'm not taking crypto currently but
if the market swings back up
i might consider that crypto [ __ ]
yeah so oh this is oh this is what you
look like okay that is pretty serious
what's going on here
well i was dressed as a gigas chad uh
with my fellow giga chad and so you went
to an nft convention with logan paul and
you're just going to call and you're
like logan are very close as you know
he's one of my best friends he's a real
friend he actually checks in on me not
just when he needs to have you know some
revamping of his dead podcast because
his is number one in the world as you
know and um the truth is me and logan
are very tired like this and uh pretty
much the opposite of you and me
yeah he's like yo i got this little scam
thing i'm doing at this crypto [ __ ]
oh leave him alone dude leave logan out
of this
paul
hi pitchfall what do you got now oh
that's a big ass back hey don't talk to
high-pitched paul thank you paul he's
going to close the blinds finally [ __ ]
oh i'm a director let me set up my
camera pointing directly into the bright
window
i know so much about film
that wasn't me that was high pitched
paul hey hi pitch
dude
shut up oliver i want to talk to high
pitch
what's up pie pitch
get out of here dude
stupid
[Music]
all right well whatever
look dude
it's one thing for me to come on your
show and do my promotion as you know i
have a tour coming up as you know i am
throwing the greatest entertainment
experience ever with my festival fire
festival but it's another thing for you
to go and just literally try to destroy
me and crucify me with media clips that
have been blown out of proportion it's
not [ __ ] cool dude i said it's fake
it's not fake it's a real article and
it's done damage to my brand deals hey
let me ask you a question um
who's so you have you have someone who's
headlining your your event
i am oh i'm the headliner it's my event
but i'm very excited to announce
we have brought on
my childhood favorite band
smash mountain
smash mouth ladies and gentlemen
really you're gonna be smash mouth is
coming out of the fire festival
how'd you pull that man i'm sure they're
in high demand these days dude
yeah i mean it wasn't easy man it's
something i've been working on for about
two years yeah the truth is this was
something that's you know i had to open
up my piggy bank and i
pretty much signed up to do this nft
event so i could afford to bring him out
so it was like one show for another show
and um yeah they're probably doing an
international tour right now they're
super busy
oh would you [ __ ] off don't think i
can't pick up on your sarcasm
no smash about the super relevant uh i
i've been wrong yeah they have hits hey
remember that remember that they did the
soundtrack for shrek
yeah i do remember and it's one of my
favorite movies so yeah i do remember
hey i've got a question
i have a sh i have a question you know
what's funny go ahead you look a whole
lot like shrek right now
i like shrek i'm down with all that
you look like you look like prince
farquaad [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] off dude i'm about to walk
wait i want to ask you questions about
your show come back
you know i thought smash bath had fallen
off but now that i see them on your
lineup now i'm a believer
that's not funny
it's not funny i'm a believer
if i try
hey i'll say your festival has a
all-star lineup
[Applause]
all-star was one of their big songs i
was pretty weird i'll give you that one
hey let me ask you
um so your fire festival's in the middle
of the summer right it's gonna be like
walking on the sun out there isn't it
walking on the sun
that's another smash mouth song another
smash mouth song remember that one
i might as well be walking on the sun
i love that song
it was catchy
do they do you think that they uh like
the moniker shrek rock or is that
demeaning to what they do
you ask me i mean i would take that as a
compliment i mean sometimes on my shows
people will bring signs that say
shrek rock and um i take it out of the
highest form of compliment but when it
comes from someone like you who's making
a mockery of my life's work that's when
it becomes a problem
it's not necessarily an insult it's just
their work conjures a time when sh when
it was about shrek and rock and roll
where people talked real [ __ ] fast
and they made shrek soundtrack music
that's what the [ __ ] is up
hey you got a lot of projects lined up
let me ask you something how do you keep
up with all that it's like the projects
keep on coming in they don't stop coming
they don't stop coming in they don't
stop running they don't understand but
they live for fun your brain gets smart
but your head gets dumb
that's all that's another smash mouth
layer
you know what that was impressive you
managed to stay in key for that one i'll
give you that one
who else is going to be at the festival
i hope there's going to be so many
things to do so many things to see
so what's wrong with taking these nuts
in your mouth
i'm not amused hey how long is your
concert going to be because i'll never
know if i don't go
hey we've got some really big acts here
we've got
little hoodie the tick tock superstar
wait for him
yeah
they've got a lot of tick-tockers okay
we've got johnny who's a tick-tocker
we've got swako who's a tick-tocker and
of course we have myself who's the
biggest tick-tocker in the last five
years so it's going to be a tick-tock
real-life experience can you stop
[ __ ] honking
no it sounds great man stop hey can i
ask you a question is there going to be
like a big tent with like red and white
stripes with animals inside
like you know a circus
like a circle that's very very funny
ethan
no turn the [ __ ] song
i can't work under this condition
it's going to be the greatest
entertainment experience and it'll be
nothing like a circus yeah
stop
at what point are you gonna be jumping
through a hoop on fire
that's actually not a bad idea
yeah
i like that
well i wanna just ask this okay i put
together
you said it yourself
in all starcasts yeah an incredible show
that is going to be the show of the
millennium
i just want to know
where will you be august 4th
i'll be there man
is this a [ __ ] promise or is this a
[ __ ] promise
it's a i mean it's like it's like a
tentative yes
that doesn't sound like a problem i'll
take it
yeah this that sounds like if you oh
don't pull these [ __ ] pictures out
yeah no it's interesting because you
have jumped through a hoop on fire
before
yeah i have and that's very funny of you
to make the comparison but yes i did
jump through a hoop and departed yeah
no but i think we're all gonna be there
so how many tickets do we need guys like
12 13. like two dozen if you could just
amazing two dozen sale now and you can
get tickets forever you want to get as
many as you want there's still a couple
hundred left anybody who wants to go i
think there's probably enough for you
and all your family and friends and and
any fans who want to go this is your
last chance to get tickets for this show
or the tour because as you know these
shows will be selling out and i will say
if you go to san diego at a fire
festival you will get a chance to meet
your favorite super couple ethan
connolly no no no no no no we're not wow
you guys are doing a meet and greet no
yes we've arranged some kind of we go
there you're probably not going to see
us so don't buy tickets for that reason
i just want to no no no
i think any fan of ethan and hila should
know they will be there there's a chance
i won't even be we'll be taking pictures
oliver's just going to ghost us again i
don't even know
my wife isn't doing this all right last
time i sorted you out and then you're oh
now you can't make it because dan can't
get in touch with my dan well guess what
you don't go to my game you go to me
hey i'm the guy who's doing live i was
texting you bro it was
hey why did you get why the [ __ ] how did
you get banned on our kanye after ian
got you that gracious game
oliver tree
you have been removed as a moderator
from our kanye you didn't even have
moderator powers it was just a
ceremonial title
what did you do
i
may or may not have put some of my views
on there oh god radical white
supremacist [ __ ]
is the guy who literally tried to blow
up the nra building
first of all i didn't try to blow it up
let's just be clear about it well let's
be clear here because technically you
made threats
i didn't no no let's be very clear
there's some footage we could probably
pull up a clip zach uh you think you
could play some kind of drum roll and
maybe uh
ian somebody else can pull up a clip of
this because there's
video footage of ethan threatening to
bomb u.s soil so not a [ __ ] chance
[Music]
no drum roll what so what why did you
get do you know why he got banned from
our kanye ian i know why i was banned
okay tell me
because
i said
that i wasn't particularly the biggest
fan
of the new yeezy slides i like the old
ones and
a lot of people were offended by that
and i would not say who but
ian may no names and maybe he can
mention some of them
you know what's funny based on what i
know of the kanye subreddit that kind of
jives
yeah that makes it something they would
do
it's the message i got was more like
they thought
well they wanted sort of like a like a
real
like a real musician to
moderate
such a big artist
oh [ __ ] off ian you are so full of [ __ ]
right now
i'm just a messenger maybe smash mouth
to be interested
oh no they won't be
because i spent a lot of time moderating
that [ __ ] reddit channel and i will
say this
it was a waste of [ __ ] time and i
would not let my close friends at
smashmouth waste another [ __ ] day and
i want to say this you guys are talking
about oh yeah people who run their
reddit well guess what who's running
your reddit because every time i post on
there my [ __ ] gets taken down
immediately it's [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
yeah i set up an auto mod a while ago
everything about you obviously
now i notice anytime someone posts about
me it gets taken off your stupid [ __ ]
reddit page within the first five
minutes yeah the name is blacklist yeah
it's off topic obviously off topic
unrelated
hey you recently threw out the first pit
stop what dude
no you're not supposed to talk about
this i didn't [ __ ] throw the first
pitch i was supposed to but i couldn't
make it what are you doing
no you couldn't make it
wait oliver went to the padres game and
threw the first pitch now you guys
remember
when i threw a first pitch that was a
perfect one right actually what one did
you throw exactly what baseball game was
that hold on oliver ella did i mine was
perfect i thought yeah and so and what i
was like dude if you go to a ball game
and throw a shitty first pitch that's
like lifetime humiliation i had like a
whole spiel about it
well oliver tree wasted no time going
out there and
humiliating himself here he is at the
padres
throwing the first page don't
this is the ceremonial first pitch oh my
god bro you threw it right at the ground
have you ever thrown a baseball in your
life
dude you don't understand the condition
this is the ceremony why'd you wear
those big ass pants dude like you
stepped on the pants and then tripped
okay let me at least speak again let me
talk this is the ceremony let me watch
the whole clip okay
she throws it at the ground falls
oliver tree
who
is a record producer a singer
no i wasn't crying i got dirt in my eye
why did he call you a comedian
all right what do you want to say about
that national travesty that's the worst
thing to happen in america
not playing the [ __ ] clip so the fact
that you would do that
on your shitty little podcast luckily no
one's watching but i have to say this
you that is the ultimate betrayal as
someone who i once considered a friend
very long ago before i first met you i
want to say this
i want to say this
go say it bro
spit it out man this isn't the oliver
tree podcast we got other [ __ ] to talk
about [ __ ] do something like that
ethan you're so self-centered so supple
it's always about you
what did you want to say man just i want
to say something can i speak are you
going to just keep talking over me well
if you keep going i want to say
something i want to say something it's
[ __ ] just saying i want to say
something shut the [ __ ] up
okay
you want to watch this [ __ ] who's never
thrown a ball in her life can you stop
talking not even from america oh here's
your first stitch oh very funny you're
playing in a basement
no we did a long we would
even compare this you've never been
under real pressure all you do look at
that look at that damn
all you do is critique other people
while you do nothing with your life get
me up on that mountain dude get me on
that mound
you're not getting on that amount it's
only for real celebrities first of all
the only amount i'm getting on is you're
going
to
be a threat on u.s soil you may do some
type of domestic terrorist act and i
can't put my name out on the line for
you stop what the [ __ ]
all right what did you want to say what
do you want i speak or not
yes yeah i'll it's all free i want to
say something
okay what happened here
was completely out of my control
i was hanging out
in the dugout with some of the players
beforehand i've got a lot of fans in
major league baseball and what ended up
[ __ ]
can you stop playing the [ __ ] clip
dude i just thought he'd be interesting
can you play it while he talks
no we can't i want to share everybody's
small and then this big and i'll keep
playing it go ahead
okay
so what happened was
i was hanging out with some of the
players in the dugout beforehand and i
don't know if you've ever been to dugout
obviously you haven't um but there is a
very big
snack selection and so
inside the players rooms they have this
whole kitchen and all these different
foods so i was eating for free i hadn't
eaten all day and you know i love mini
corn dogs and i was eating like at least
i would say
three dozens of these things and
i don't know if you've had any of these
things recently but they're really
greasy
corn dogs especially the mini ones are
cooked at a certain temperature which
actually doesn't burn off the oil so
they're covered in oil so i'm my hands
are completely oiled i'm trying to rub
them off on my jinkos but the oil just
keeps sticking
to my pants but it stays on my hand so
i'm getting i have this essentially
lubricated hands
and you're telling me that professional
baseball players eat corn dogs before a
game of course what do you think dude
that's they live off that [ __ ] yeah no
that's not that didn't happen let me
speak you know
i go out there
i i go and i practice in the bowl ring
and keep in mind i just spent the last
three months rehearsing and training if
this guy is a professional baseball
player
i'm not going to say the name but
it rhymes with shmerry schmons
barry bonds
i don't like rhymes
can you shut the [ __ ] up can you get on
with it all right let's just do the
pinatas no let me speak so i go to throw
the first pitch it doesn't make sense
they don't need corndogs before games
athletes and i throw it and a gust of
wind comes from nowhere knocking me down
as i throw the pitch and you have to
keep in mind dude my entire family flew
out my cousins came from new mexico my
grandma came from cincinnati i'm
literally your dad came from jail
it was the most embarrassing moment of
my [ __ ] life dude and literally
everyone i know was watching and i just
literally dropped the ball literally and
figuratively
hey you know what logan paul should turn
this clip into a nft
dude logan paul is doing a lot better
than you right now okay
don't put him down yeah there's a good
chance he's being investigated by the
[ __ ] fbi too that's not him that's
his brother
no that's him you have heard a dink donk
yet or no
no i haven't
yeah just keep burying your head in the
sand about dinko don't get my favorite
coin i want you to think on my face
oliver provided the music for the more
recent nfp project that logan did not
the uh yeah i was not the one that logan
used my song for guess what he actually
used my song for something and he paid
me a handsome fee and you've never done
anything i've still yet to receive one
check that's like saying that's like
saying oh pablo escobar he was so
generous yeah no [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
like he's
all of his money is like stolen his
blood money he's just sitting on
billions of dollars of like unmarked
[ __ ]
paul is not a bills
he's technically a trillionaire
oh
all right he has money
in oil and other investments so he's
doing cards he doesn't need to do rug
polls like your other friends he
literally did look up ding donk he
literally did a rug pull
stop and he went
he goes
i'm just saying bro you're [ __ ]
pissing me off right now don't talk
about logan like that oh i know you guys
are [ __ ] man and you're nobody no i
know you guys are homies you know what i
think of you
i think you're a [ __ ] low-life
scumbag bottom of the [ __ ] barrel
feeder and the thing i think i would
like to do to a [ __ ] ethan klein is
right here right now
you [ __ ] sorry poor bastard
oh no
[Music]
wait can we can we see it up close
[Music]
let me see what it looks like
that doesn't look anything like me dude
ah it does it looks like right the
shape's a little off
it's not fat enough
it looks like you about 10 years ago
yeah is he wearing slides let me see the
feet don't show the feet don't get them
oh damn the tiny feet slides hey oliver
look what i got
i got a corn dog to see if i can still
throw a ball afterwards
don't eat that
i'm gonna hold i'm gonna handle it
my hands are getting greasy
corn dog
okay let's just get this [ __ ] over
[Music]
all right oliver's going to bring the
heat to me
careful don't break the window man that
position is kind of sudden
wow is something i should have done a
long time ago okay i saw what you did
the [ __ ] pinata of me and that
was the most disrespectful thing the
fact that you would do that on your
birthday shows what kind of person you
are
you are disgusting and you are so so so
[ __ ] gross
see that
see that ethan
god you're gonna break that
window oh i should have done a long time
ago
i think i was stronger i think i think i
broke mine faster
[Music]
oliver is weak
he swings like a girl
[Music]
what's inside
what's inside bro
what's inside the pinata
what's inside the piano
it's the cursed brain we stopped it with
the first rib i told you you get that
[ __ ] back you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] look
at your hip hairline that's not surreal
from yourself
look inside the pinata bro your ass is
cursed and you accepted it as a gift bro
seals the curse
that steals it nobody you know that
you're a [ __ ] nominee
look at this [ __ ] sorry sorry excuse
i'm a [ __ ] human
oh my god
you're caving your skull dude
you're [ __ ] worthless oh god oh my
god
a long time ago
[Laughter]
no no no oliver don't
no i'm serious do not burn the bram it's
cursed bro don't do it freaking curse
bro
oh my god this is such a bad idea
and he learned you're amazing and i
don't know why you put up with your dad
you didn't leave him
i wouldn't
[Laughter]
a long long long time ago
[Music]
like a [ __ ] news
he going to jump through that fire once
he lights it yeah she's going to jump
through it juggling
all right dude have you ever let a match
before
hello what
this is awesome man
this is really cool
that's the whole [ __ ] thing on here
okay that's probably too much
it's okay let him dance that's probably
a lot he knows what he's doing
he's going to burn down his whole
neighborhood after that curse bro you
this is so lame
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay there we go
[Music]
hey olivia this is pretty good what
brand is that it's from trader joe's
it's a turkey oh that's a trader joe's
yeah
but there's one left in the freezer if
anyone wants oh i asked lena to make it
from around the message
i'm going to destroy him on the stage
is nobody listening
i don't even know that you could
microwave those they taste really good
yeah for real what nobody cares you get
this [ __ ] dog over me
all right you're breathing in that first
anyway dude
good luck with all that okay buddy
i want you to pay me back my [ __ ]
glasses that you broke
it's all about the classes wait no you
guys
you're good man it's nice
i need you to get your tickets for
firemen right now bro i need it i'm down
back so stop the [ __ ] exits
[Music]
yeah
file over
all right
all over three
that sucked
was it i wasn't paying attention which
part was sad just i don't know the
ending the crying yeah the crying
the pathetic right yeah the begging the
pleading
we got that cursed brim back to him
though
yeah i guess that's the end though
because he didn't win that [ __ ]
i noticed she left some on the ground um
interesting
you're not gonna finish that right
oh my god
the corn dog was the best part of that
yeah that was yeah that was most
interesting i didn't know that
yeah i think i bought those actually
they've been in the fridge for a while
uh
well if you guys want to go to fire
go to olivetree.com right
and you can buy tickets
don't buy it to meet us just to be very
clear
there's a good chance i won't be there
and if i am there i'll you won't
probably ever see me
okay
thank you
guys how come the view i noticed the
views aren't getting up that high is it
the title
do we need to rejigger the title
i don't know leading with wendy williams
just saying
what oh ace fest well it hasn't happened
yet guys
it's this weekend
talk about dojicap being a weirdo
that's in the talk is that a big story
though is that like a headline story
it's juicy to me i followed it i thought
it was pretty interesting yeah
let's talk about it i briefly saw people
talk about it
it is very interesting to be totally
honest
and i like doja cat i think she's funny
and cool
and it quirky
mm-hmm you love that for her i know
schnapp is so fun online too
but what do you think do you think she
just kind of
i think releasing dms is a weird thing
to do without saying anything even
though she was posting
on twitter publicly about liking the
actor
i think i don't think the dm's made her
look bad they didn't at all and so i
thought they were just in on this goof
they were doing together i thought so
too
uh just a note on the live numbers yeah
i forgot i saw this right before the
show like the entire internet in canada
and i think even some of the northern
united states is out what there's like a
massive outage no really what
the whole country of canada is so how
does that happen
they're protesting for jordan peterson
that was the other side that he got
banned off twitter wait actually how
does that happen how does the whole
country lose internet
yeah i'm not sure let's see
canada internet outage let me see what
the status on that is we'll see who
cancels who
government operation i did not put my i
guess one of the biggest the biggest
isps rogers communications
so you know it'd be like uh
yeah according to cbs news internet
traffic has dropped by 75
in canada dude where are my canadians at
so we're missing our no it's our
canadian you think that has to do with
it
and you said something there it's not
like we have a sizeable
it could be another corn dog past that
[ __ ] bro what are you doing
here's waiting for ilo to leave
i can eat this before she gets back
slam that dog we got another dog slam
that cd
yeah oh mama to leave
[Music]
number
[Music]
yeah they
one of our canadian fans just said we
have a duopoly between two telecom
companies and one is down you can't use
debit across the country either wow
and what you said some of america
doesn't have internet i i saw that on
twitter earlier from what i'm reading on
this article that sounds like that was
probably not correct because it's just
this specific isp rogers communications
have some canadians in the chat but yeah
seems like majority is out
[Music]
[Music]
what
you may not
no chad i still have a corn dog for
myself beauty
i thought you took that from me cutie
you guys want to do the sprite challenge
i promised i'd do it
you promised wait wait wait wait wait i
interrupted the dojo well let's do this
right okay and then we'll get into the
doju thing okay
but do you think dojo was like
wrong or snow was wrong i thought it was
weird i didn't necessarily think anyone
was like explicitly wrong
i think it sucks because they're both
cool
but
no
i wasn't like did noah respond to her
ever he deleted the well she
allegedly had a conversation with him
before her life and he took the tick
tock down before she
like called him a snake and all that
stuff
i if i had to
thank you
um
i think doge is the one that escalated
it too far well he's also 17. right
that's a big factor yeah but even if he
wasn't
like
the post didn't make her look bad at all
at all and so
i feel like she could have just let it
go
yeah
but we'll talk about that
all right so this is the sprite
challenge this is a tick tock thing
right
i get one two oh everyone's gonna try it
so you just gotta chug this [ __ ] not not
burp not burp yeah easy
so yeah i've never done my life this is
a tick-tock thing i've seen a lot of
people do it
and i've seen a lot of people not be
able to do it
so it's doable
i can't chug a whole
bottle like that
yeah i don't know how good i am at
chugging that seems like the hard part
for sure yeah i can't even chug a bottle
of water yeah like regular water you
can't crush a bottle not that bad chug
in the water
all right so so i just there's no time
limit i just get it down without burping
yeah you don't even have to chug it just
you have to get it all down without
burping
i want to say before we start dan was
very cocky about this i was just saying
oh you were you want to go first i want
you so confident or maybe we'll just do
it at the same time i mean
you guys started already
oh we're stuck
[Music]
it's cold
it's hard to drink because it's cold
[Music]
damn look at dan go that's good
that diet sprite it's different
it's the best
it's not bad right
i could already burp
[Music]
oh my god
it feels so wrong not to burp when you
have to
there it is [ __ ] it i'm not even trying
this [ __ ]
my body's been through enough
whoa
libya who is that
that was not me that was me right into
the mic
sorry guys sorry people at home
[Music]
dan well dan's our real competitor
dan's going for it
yeah he's going for it do you feel like
you need to burp dan a little bit just a
little bit
wow those bubbles are aggressive yeah
it's very
sprite is very carbonated
wait dan is just
a little bit left
oh you trying to get the carbonation out
is that what's happening there it's just
showing off
oh
[Applause]
wow now why would you so confident that
you could do that because i don't i'm
not a big burper
like i just don't burp very often i'm
definitely going to burp in a minute
though
it's okay if you do it afterwards yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
like
the inclination to do it yet no i
definitely need it
but generally i i don't burp very much
from carbonation i don't know lena i saw
you you did it even better than i did i
couldn't i couldn't even
yeah i think i got like more than a
halfway through yeah
very impressive but dan on the other
hand is the sprite king spray king baby
oh ian have you are you go doing it
still ian
yeah
let's get ian on cam
ian's going for it
[Music]
ian is going for the full clear there
two absolute legends in one office wow
and damn
look at this
two absolute beef wait cam said that he
also finished oh cam shoot cut the
camera i finished before dan whoa whoa
what a king
turns out it's not that hard of a
challenge for half
of people it seems like
that was why i was confused when people
were saying like
the the sprite challenge i thought it
was going to be like a two liter oh oh
my god
ian you okay over there buddy
yeah yeah yeah really weird i still
haven't burped i don't need to but
that's what i'm saying like i i don't
have
the ability i can't burp on command like
a lot of people do
so same interesting
i just had like oh
for me i couldn't even i couldn't get
halfway well i have bad dirt as well so
maybe i don't [ __ ] with the girl gang
it's a bad idea to [ __ ] with that girl
you have gerd
you take anything for it i always have
like zantac and uh pepto-bismol around
the house or tom's you take uh parilla
sack yeah i've done probably sex too
for like a two-week thing and stop no
because you're supposed to take it every
day yeah i know i've never i haven't
done that because if it doesn't help if
you just take it i know it doesn't do
anything
cheers but but it's it's great that's
right yeah no it works it's great
wait some people in the chat are saying
you're supposed to uh
you were supposed to chug it oh well
that well that yeah
that's really hard yeah i'll get out one
go
i mean i almost did that i mean everyone
i've seen
yeah
he was going straight he just took
he stopped in between but that's what
everyone was doing on tick-tock too
yeah i might need to
somebody burp me like a baby later i can
do that damn you can do that for me yeah
you want me a little pat on the back
yeah well just just the just
excuse me there's an addition to that
challenge too with a banana or something
do you guys know about oh yeah that's a
different one that's my nightmare that
makes you throw that makes you wait you
eat a banana then yeah for some reason
like you foam up super much yeah because
they're acidity
that's [ __ ] up when i was in middle
school we went on a trip to dc so it was
a bunch of eighth graders like in a
plane and you know how their tvs on the
back of
chairs there was this show where they
did the sprite banana challenge
yep and everyone was watching it around
me and it was like everybody was
watching vomit and like i couldn't
escape it it wasn't my absolute
nightmare
olivia has a vomit vomit yeah it was so
disgusting and when i heard we were
doing a sprite challenge i almost didn't
come in
yeah but you you've overcome that phobia
a bit haven't you on the show i have i
actually held a friend's hair this
semester
um
when can we get ether to eat bofa yeah
yeah yeah both of these [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
no but can you guys can we do a poll
like
tell me which is the best topic to lead
with okay and let's do a poll here it
seems like the dojo cat was showing a
lot of interest okay okay okay let's see
but yeah we're talking from just like a
trying to get people to click the video
so let's do it
for sure don't you cat
wendy
elon
keemstar i mean who gives a [ __ ] about
that game star yeah dojo for sure is
that right okay good i mean keemstar i
didn't know i didn't know it was a big
deal because that's funny because i was
following it
you know
or both
the drama isn't that juicy but just
writing dojo drama in the title might be
good because people don't know what it
is also such an unlikely duo i know what
could be beefing i'm obsessed with it
also i'm in i'm curious about doge's
obsession with that actor too
me too i get it
i know a lot of people like character
but i get it i get it but like she's
like so thirsty for him it's that
serious
i definitely think he was you know what
i'm talking about well why don't we just
talk about it yeah yeah let's do the
pull first hold on we keep like almost
talking about it yeah you're right but
let's do the pull first
how about what
what the [ __ ] you weren't doing a pull
this whole time about title
i thought what you just said let's put
this oh we already decided i changed the
title dojo cat drama sorry wait you
gotta let him start what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro is definitely the best
no dog
hunger
wait should it be dojikat versus noah
schnapps or like verse noah schnapp from
strangers first stranger things cast
doja cat versus stranger things that
seems to abstract
noah schneider things things
does everyone know who knows is though
that's why i'm saying stranger things i
think what noah schnapps is famous he
has like a gajillion followers yeah i
know
okay
shout out to uh what's his name mike
he's a fan of the show i believe finn
wolfhard yeah oh yeah friend of the show
definitely
people want me to talk about bobby lee i
mean what do you want me to say about it
what do i know
that he broke up with kalila
sad
you know maybe the mole
the mole thing
yeah do you have the clip in the
document i'll get it right now
i told bob well okay now we're getting
ahead of ourselves yeah let's talk about
the mole thing after this bobby's mad at
me
because i told him he had a mole that
looked cancerous
i said bro you guys should get that
checked out
and he met he went and it's fine and now
he's mad at me
i sent him kind of annoying i care i
care about him
dude it was [ __ ] up and i even showed
it to a b yes and amy's like yo i didn't
want to he goes after bobby leaves amy
comes up to me goes yo i don't want to
freak bobby up that [ __ ] looks cancer
he said that when bobby said that you
asked your
doctor friend i'm like i hope he wasn't
referring to me
yeah he was he he wasn't even he didn't
give the right context during that story
i said he was in pre-med school or some
[ __ ] and he yeah they don't teach a [ __ ]
about medicine but
i don't care about that
so anyway let's go with
doja cat
versus stranger things kid
[Music]
[Laughter]
cat has entered the upside down world oh
interesting
that's
your cat possessed by that yeah that's
cute but not very well that's
tongue-in-cheek
i'm down with dojo versus noah he said
someone said he's annoyed because ethan
aired bobby's health to some random
doctor friend no he's not it was a b i
said it was a b
that's not why he's annoyed
he's not really annoyed he's just joking
around yeah i'm a pinnacle of the
medical community i would never share
that publicly with anyone
yeah
go [ __ ] yourself you stupid piece of
[ __ ] hey
yo um he's not really mad you guys just
stop with the nuns they started off by
saying ethan cares so much yeah
which is true by the way
i care
and i kill
oh noah doji cat schnapps
somebody suggested that in the uh
yeah dosa schnapped
doja cat
is tongue-in-cheeks sister schnapp
though
yeah but actually maybe you did violate
hipaa law so i'm gonna have to report
you to the board yeah
we're gonna have to take away your
stethoscope sister snatched we're gonna
need that stethoscope back buddy
damn
wow sister snapped
it sounds like he's saying schnapps
so you want to do doja cat sister
schnapps
666 for that suggestion by the way shut
up poopypants my boy you guys ready this
is it
bobby lee is dying
that's the the title oh my god baby
[ __ ] up dude that's not even funny
it's a joke
jesus christ dude it's not even felt you
never get buried for that reason
i wasn't serious wait wait wait wait no
no no no you need to leave
you guys remember when we put me in a
thumbnail in the hospital y'all remember
that and then we photoshopped my face
out and put ethan's face yeah but that's
you jokes then that's you
you know zach why don't you [ __ ]
bully
[Music]
okay so let's dodge a cat sister
schnapps on noah schnapps
can we call it schister schnapp no
that's
[Laughter]
that makes no sense nobody will make any
sense of that title by anyone who's
watching the show right now
dan don't you update that [ __ ] title
we're trying to make it more clickable
and we're just making it worse way worse
way worse
though just sister snaps on no
no sister but all the rest is fine doji
cat schnapped
oh you [ __ ] did update it
well i did that a few minutes ago but i
don't
know
it could be dojicat beefing with noah
schnapp and the stranger things cast
the other actor is also included in the
story oh for they are right the guy
eddie yeah okay oh yeah
dictate that dan break this down uh
doji cat beefs with stranger things cast
wow that sounds
like i said 20 minutes ago
hold on hold on is that what you said
the last time oh yeah yeah okay doja cat
beefing over some stranger things no no
wait write it down write it down right
now i did dodge a cat beef
technically no did you say beast was
noah schnapps yeah
and stranger things yeah
no
dojo cat beefs with noah schnapps and
stranger things cast dan
wait i would
dodge a cat beefs with noah schnapp
and stranger things cast
oh my god
does a cat schnapped at the stranger
things cast
too deep missed too deep
beans on toast
beans left featuring beans on toast
so i'm cutting everybody else out of
this title
yeah there's no space for those yeah
it's way too long anymore nobody cares
about them
dojo cat beefs with noah schnapps and
stranger things cats
got it
do we like
this let's move on from the title
we need a new thumbnail cam
uploading this
discord there it is oh you already did a
thumbnail oh [ __ ] let's [ __ ] go right
now dude i like that go get it
let's get restarted
let's get the towel
man
i gotta get as close to saying the r
word as possible
when i was chopping it up trying to get
it to say let's get restarted it just
sounded like let's get
the artwork
there's no way of editing that maybe you
could get the eddie guy in there too
uh okay
why not
or that looks pretty good though i don't
want to push it all right use that one
dan for now let's do this [ __ ] show
okay
all right let's talk about doji cat
so doja cat
yes snapped on noah schnapps
let me find a doc yeah
okay so let me start from the top so
noah noah cat
that's their ship name
so it started with noah dojica tweeting
out joseph quinn finest [ __ ]
so she's been thirsting for this man
hard
and if you guys don't know who joseph
quinn is he's the guy who played eddie
the guy the rock and roll guy
uh from the new season i'll show you a
picture you guys know if you've seen it
yeah he played this guy
he [ __ ]
okay zach
so this is all does he [ __ ] harder or
less hard than
uh
ah dude who [ __ ] harder
you know i i can't let my boy you know
that pgd down you know perfect goss dong
but um
nah gosh the [ __ ] hard gossip eddie
eddie eddie [ __ ] hard but not as hard
as what about rooster from top oh
rooster fox dude wait rooster miles
teller dude that guy [ __ ] dude wait
who's rooster who
from the new top gun movie miles
jesus christ he's the thirst of the
month guy [ __ ] dude
so
this is him
now
i mean again he's like i feel like he's
like fairly normal looking am i wrong
about that i mean he's handsome he takes
care of himself he's an actor that's
cool
but he doesn't strike me as like
someone to [ __ ] throw it all away for
like dog cat did and correct me if i'm
wrong you know
god bless this man
some i usually can tell pretty well if
men are attractive or not i feel like i
have a good
uh
scale for that so i could but sometimes
i'm wrong and sometimes there's guys
that women are like i'm [ __ ] crazy
and i'm like whoa him really so
sometimes i don't get it is this man
very attractive
i think so and like
would you throw it all away for him bad
pull
he's also like so talented his acting
was ridiculous you know has he been in
other things no but did you not think he
was no he was good he was great the
metallica
no he was good i loved that was awesome
he uh i think he looked better in that
like 80s look with the hairdo and stuff
yeah i kind of think that was more
special yeah you think he looked more
attractive like this yeah when he looked
more like zach he just has kind of a
baby face he's also like smiling there
and in the others he looks
you sink better without the smile no i
love the smile oh we love this smile
i mean
but doji cat's throwing it all away for
this man she's gone public she is coming
she's risking it all for this man it's a
little nuts
interesting though eh how tall is he
just get a vibe check on that can we
every time you're obsessed says 510 510
to save
just saying
audiences split almost 50 50 on uh if
you thought or not so
but maybe she likes him because he's
like
right on the cusp sometimes you find
someone who's like just your type
and they're not conventionally
attractive
and so they that makes them almost like
uh
more attractive
i think that's what was going on with
him
especially with his look on the show
mm-hmm
it's got that like unconventional
mm-hmm
if he hits it right now for you then
you're all in
but actually seeing him like
on his regular look he looks more like a
regular
here he is kind of the bad boy thing
here would that do anything for you
got that hell razor shirt i don't know
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
that shirt's kind of crazy
personally i giving cinebite i think he
he looks better as eddie to be
completely honest with you but i think i
think he looks better as as
as uh
mr quinn i think people are falling in
love with the character right i think so
too yeah what's going on yeah
great character and the portrait i
wouldn't [ __ ] the character either just
to be clear
and i'd [ __ ] and listen
but does he [ __ ] like does he [ __ ]
not in the film he [ __ ] you never got
any in the movie no no no you're missing
the point he [ __ ] like
he's cool he [ __ ] dude
is that what being cool is
cornered bro i just cornered you no it's
not the actual sexual act i'm trying to
describe yeah it's just like he's cool
he [ __ ] you know yeah he's dope look at
him he's got tats and [ __ ]
okay but anyway
uh so so dojia cat has decided to throw
it all away for this man so she's
tweeting out joseph quinn fine as [ __ ]
this was on may 30th
okay
now fast forward
um noah schnapparinos
posted a tick tock that went very viral
your your mom no i know he erased it but
last i checked it had like
five million likes which got i don't
know that must mean like 20 30 million
views i don't know sister snapped and
what his he posted this is just a repost
uh
so wait let me
so this is what he posted so she
messages noah who is 17 he's a kid
i mean we know of them all to be kids
right
noah can you tell joseph to hit me up
so you're asking a 17 year old
to play matchmaker which is a little
whatever
but actually you know what it's it's
kind of whatever but when it gets really
weird when she starts calling him out
it's like you know you put him in that
position and then you skewered him okay
yeah sure you know what i mean
but also the can you tell him to hit me
up it's like you already tweeted about
him very publicly i mean if he wanted to
he would it's not a secret at this point
so
exactly exactly a little weird
yeah that's what i'm saying she's
thirsting for this man so hard
yeah
it's it's crazy it's a nuts man just to
be clear because some people are
confused joseph quinn
is not a minor he's 29. noah yeah is 17.
yeah i don't know how so many people are
confused in the chat about that noah
plays will buyers on stranger things
i just showed a picture of him they're
two different people yeah
audio i don't know if someone just said
audio audio audio oh that's [ __ ] with
you guys bad right
thank you for drawing attention to it
blame jimmy
hold it yeah apparently jimmy lee has
ruined this podcast for dan and zach
because now
you've watched spam chat audio audio
audio dude they don't know if it's an
actual audio issue or not
he's like even like texting me and cam
like audio audio and then he's like
sending clips of him saying audio and
then memes of him saying audio
just never ending man poor zach plays i
love music on instagram and people be
commenting audio audio
[ __ ] up dude
jamie said
i'm sorry but eddie looks like mark
zuckerberg
so there you go
daddy zuckerberg
nah i don't see that anyway so
she messaged noah
she says can you tell joseph to hit me
up wait no does he have a girlfriend and
then noah said left my ass off slide
into his dms
she says i don't know his ig or twitter
he doesn't
have anywhere to slide in and then he's
like here's her
instagram right here man
he's kind of over her [ __ ] you could
tell
yeah i don't want to get in the middle
of this
also like here's his instagram it's easy
to find
yeah
because she wanted that
she wanted that direct one you wanted
like his phone number yes yeah yeah yeah
yeah
also she um
she very quickly like
said wait does he have a girlfriend like
she almost realized she's being so
ridiculous
well that's good she'd be respectful i
thought it was nice yeah she didn't want
to she didn't want to because it yeah it
was like placed in the real world yeah
i'm not just like not just he's hot on
twitter instagram and tick tock the best
way to meet girls but yeah i don't know
i don't know the whole thing's kind of
weird
my take is justice for will he's just
been through enough
speaking of the character there's [ __ ]
on him
his friends are ignoring him how old is
dojika
let's see
i think people i think twenty yeah yeah
i was gonna guess 29. the same age
younger than that but you know i don't i
don't think i don't think dojo cats is
used to being rejected right like if she
if she's
interested in a guy then it's like gg
i'm sure but that's kind of like part of
what's uh
a little weird here
she's just so thirsty for it
because uh you you only showed one tweet
but she was tweeting about him a few
times right was that right about that
yeah she was like in replies and stuff
too
so it was like a difference between like
just making a joke like oh he's so hot
he's so and then hitting up yeah but
then it's really maybe that's why she
was thought this was
she was offended because she's like oh i
realized oh yeah now that i look like a
creep yeah maybe
because it was like it was fun when it
was yeah it was fun
it was a reverend but now we're taking
action about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
well so anyway noah posted this on tick
tock it got like a gazillion views
but i don't think anyone was really mad
at um
so what did he post just the picture or
what's the what was his tick tock that
that was it that was it
oh someone said here's another one dojo
cat look how fine joseph quinn is
she says it's [ __ ] criminal
so maybe also she's trying to get with
him right and maybe she's just
embarrassed by this it's just
embarrassing maybe but nobody was really
mad at her right nobody really cared
about when she was tweeting about him
yeah i it was everybody after this
oh i didn't see after this what happened
when noah posted it i just liked it and
i was like yes love dosha love noah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i think people were like
oh so cute they're talking
about yeah i think she was embarrassed
for sure yeah
so then what happened next
was she went on a live
and she went off on noah she caught him
like a snake and [ __ ] i was like whoa
damn chill
so i haven't seen that i i saw people
talk about it yeah here it is this this
is when it really heated up and people
started talking wait what she's super
nice at first and then she just she like
let's go a little bit
your your mom um i think you guys have
the wrong link in here
this right here is the
um
not the right link
so
they talked before
she made this live which is interesting
too
her and noah
yeah
issue
is it the right url now
it's in discord
thank you
oh that new thumbnail's good kim
all right so here's doja on the noah
schnapples
you like schnapple
is that the name of that drink snapple
oh schnapper noah schnapples
all right here we go she's about to snap
on him
i hope hopefully you're recording this
so that i don't have to do it
i tried to make a tick tock like a three
she's this is a message to the world
everyone record this minute tick tock
and it didn't work
um
i had to like do it like three times
without cringing
and that was impossible so
uh i'm just gonna say something right
now about the whole [ __ ] uh
the noah schnapp thing
i think that
to be fair first let's be let's be
try to be chill about it to be fair this
is like
a kid
like noah is like i don't know how old
he is but he's not even over like
there's no way he's over there why don't
you know how old he is you just look it
up he's 17.
hard he might be like i could be wrong
um
but like
when you're that young you make mistakes
you do dumb [ __ ] i'm like trying to be
super fair donations
you do dumb [ __ ] you say dumb [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] up relationships with
people you
you make mistakes like you're supposed
to so that you know
that's one of my favorite things when
people do serious stuff
oh i hate to bring it up but like
my favorite one obviously is the tomato
incident
you know what i'm talking about
i mean that is just dude you gotta love
tik tok for that
i should do that i should do some
serious ass thing
and then uh
wait i thought this was this is tick
tock live yeah that so that you know not
to do it in the future like i i did my
share of [ __ ] ups so that i don't [ __ ]
up again
um
but the fact that
i love that this
person that noah did that
like went and posted a private
conversation between me and him
also it wasn't like a super intimate
like confide it was like three yeah
messages and he was kind of over it from
the beginning
i think that i get her frustration like
i always always hate when people do that
to anybody
if something was sent in private and
then you post it publicly it just
sucks because you didn't plan for that
but with that being said she was
tweeting about him
already and it was becoming a meme so
maybe noah kind of thought the whole
thing is a meme that's why he posted it
yeah yeah because it would turn into
this whole thing
but you know
i listen she's way more famous than me
when i have any conversation like that i
assume it's public at this point because
it happened to us already yeah a lot of
times every time i'll never forget the
first times that it happened to us the
feeling of betrayal is like
next level
you know because you're like dude you
know it just texted you this i pretty
much
anytime i put anything in writing i
assume there's a possibility it can
become public
that's how we do that's like how we live
now but we
didn't
before it happened to us
doge is getting those hard lessons boys
yo but do they hook up that's the
question
that is the question
is
so
unbelievably like socially unaware
and whack
i totally disagree i think seeing the
screenshot
there was so little dialogue between
them
i don't think it was like socially
unaware or you know black or anything i
think it was totally understandable like
i was saying she's already made it such
a meme that you can understand where he
was coming from it's not like they were
talking about something super secretive
and
but the truth is coming out is that it's
not a meme first she really wants to
[ __ ] this guy yeah she really wants this
man
she's living for him she's giving it all
up for this man
before i saw the live because we just
found out about this right before the
show olivia was telling me um i thought
it was just dosha memeing because she
always gets involved in like trending
stuff until i saw this live the live is
where it's like okay she was meaning she
want to be going in on him like this
people are saying she's the socially
honor one unaware
yeah that might be true you know
and especially with the age difference
when you are talking about someone who's
10 years younger than you
12
12 years younger well i thought we said
she's 29. she's 26. she's 26. oh oh my
bad my bad that is so true
james charles knows something about that
and like
you know what i mean like that's like
borderline snake [ __ ]
dude that do you
stop it you can't say that that's so
[ __ ] up to put that out there against
dear sweet noah schnappolino
and right after this she calls him a
weasel oh let's hear it
like that's like
that's like weasel [ __ ]
no doji he's not your friend he's just
some kid weasley little liar dude [ __ ]
chill girl what a [ __ ] you have a
weasley little she went too far dude
wait people are saying ace fest canceled
that can't be true i'm i'm i'm no i'm
looking i'm looking i don't know i'm on
austin's it's clickbait
right now are you sure
i'm watching it right now
oh it's just click bait
they literally have links to the tickets
in the description of the video wait it
was an ace family video called ace fest
cancel it's called it's canceled can't
believe it oh what [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they're starting to sell tickets like
the day before let's go
i thought it was sold out
you know what ace fest is you're gonna
turn into a fan and fan meet up for us
and we're just gonna go there to meet
you guys
would that be awesome
that's what's gonna happen bro we're
gonna we're pushing mad tickets for ace
fest
no for real guys don't do that one it's
gonna be like 110 degrees in lancaster
so your life is in peril if you go to
ace fest not even kidding
two the guys i don't want to pay ace
fest okay so please don't pay them and
three
we need to see the real situation there
okay i don't want more people there
than there should be because they want
to come meet the guys don't do it
there's a chance you'll die bro if you
go to lancaster tomorrow 110 degrees in
lancaster
[ __ ]
is it really that hot tomorrow dan the
forecast
earlier in the week i looked and it was
supposed to be over a hundred let me see
tomorrow that's hot saturdays hey that
is 100 degrees
dude dude you do not want to be there i
guarantee you oh that's hot
that's the best application for that
sound by zach just literally that's
literal yeah yeah that's that's quite
true
anyway dojo it's quite beautiful and
like like i'm not saying that
encapsulates his entire tonality like
noah is not like
the definition like i wouldn't
imagine he is maybe he is like maybe he
isn't like a whole snake
shut the [ __ ] up girl
you are
completely so unwarranted
totally because you know that
her friend
yeah you're gonna give him a lot of [ __ ]
after this did that happen did he get
[ __ ]
i
mean but like
those are embarrassing things for
someone to say about you to so many
people
like to be called socially unaware right
a snake a weasel
that should actually that's very painful
stuff and that stuff will follow him
especially if he's a fan of hers
and he's he's like a young i'm on the
internet poppin i feel like he must be
yeah that stuff's gonna follow him man
by the way thank you it's just a prank
oh wait no h3 title cast
50 gifted subs appreciate you god bless
god bless thank you thank you
it's a prank bro
dojo
[Music]
you know
um
but like
that's what i didn't see him that way i
made an assumption that he was gonna be
like chill about it and he went and like
shared information that i didn't feel
comfortable with him sharing and and
then i understand that other people are
going to like roll their eyes and be
like oh [ __ ] please like
you just tweeted that he's fine
which is like okay
but like
the intention behind it it's like
i'm i'm going to tweet some [ __ ] that's
going to get a reaction because it's a
meme and it's dumb and like but that
wasn't it
he exposed you that you trying to get
[ __ ] which is fine
but would it just be better if she's
like ah he got me dude i'm so thirsty
for him
yeah he's a sweet [ __ ] rat there's
snake emojis somebody kill him
there are just snakes in his comments
that's [ __ ] up he's just a kid man you
didn't even do anything wrong yeah that
shit's painful that should hurt yeah
taylor swift wrote a whole damn album
because she got so many snake emojis
just saying pop culture reference here
you with me on that
reputation
[Laughter]
thanks bro
yeah i don't know it's kind of weird i
don't like it
i like dojo though still
you know it was weird pretty crazy
you know what i mean like
yes he's attractive
and i'm attracted to him but i hate the
idea of like
there's just something very weird it's
like a very degrading and and um
it's just exploitative it's like
exploitative behavior
dude this is not she need to talk you
need to be
sharing this with your therapist not
your institute your tick tock live this
is a lot to put out there
and and it's embarrassing it is
embarrassing that but you did it it's
like super embarrassing
um
yo has this guy noish or what's his name
the guy she's in love with uh joseph has
he said anything about this like imagine
what he thinks about all this
no he hasn't said anything about it this
reminds me of high school it's
embarrassing like
all this drama middle school
middle school yeah middle school you
pass a girl a note and then everyone
finds out and you're like
middle school people would send
screenshots of like emails or whatever
ims
wow
why she's so desperate stoja cat
it doesn't look good
it is humid humanizing though we're all
desperate losers honestly at the end of
the day
we're just desperate like uh poor james
charles yeah yeah oh god i'm desperate
i'm just honestly i have to admit
something really embarrassing i'm i'm
desperate there it is
that's kind of all i have to say
you said a lot i'm really embarrassed
like it's not the end of the [ __ ]
world like i flirt with people on the
internet
um
i flirt with like everybody on the
internet it's like totally okay
but it's the intention behind like when
you go out when you like
when you make the choice to message
somebody hey like blah blah blah blah
but this is private like i didn't tell
him that yeah i didn't tell him not to
post it because you don't expect people
to do that because it's not normal to do
that no you will it's like it's
literally not cool now you won't have to
message people asking
but like
i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets
yeah noah schnapp
yeah that was way too much
but there you have it huh
yeah
doji cat taking it too far but we still
love her
we still stand her but she she did know
a schnapple's dirty on that one man
he's gonna get a lot of grief for that
for a long time
undeserved sister snapped
there you have it
fascinating
absolutely riveting stuff
[Applause]
how long we've been going because i i
how much i just want to do two hours
today because theodore
i'm sad to say
very sad to say
theodore caught it he got sick man
poor guy
got it this morning he's running a fever
and i'm
worried about him
well we've been going for an hour and 48
minutes
um
so what else we got i want to do two
hours we got r kelly
g lane tobiscus with kyle rittenhouse
that's just so funny i mean if we only
have time for like one more thing which
it sounds like we do
i would suggest keemstar
shut up uh
yeah okay sure
what were you doing it's pretty funny i
was just scanning through the
screen shut up shut up
yeah [ __ ] it the keem video is funny
you know i got i can't miss the chance
it's so good but i feel like it's going
to turn into something longer well let's
see so here's keemstar so what happened
here keemstar went on a podcast and i
don't know what i didn't even know how
that's possible
how people still have this man on on
their podcast is
because you get gold like this are you
kidding me we should have them on for us
they do it for us
i guess it is yeah we're probably the
greatest beneficiary yeah yeah giving us
so much content
all right so here he is with the whole
uh
interface of people
oh the whole mole story yeah so bobby
lee well do you have the clip of bobby
lee yeah
very top of the dock
all right so bobby lee went on and he
talked about the most add episode wait
why are we back on bobby yeah i forgot
to finish the story and people wanted to
know about him
so bobby lee
here let's watch what he says
go ahead i know by the way we're going
on tiger belly next week
no it's next week yes
so we'll we'll have the
opportunity to talk it out that'll be
fun yeah but um
here listen to this eat it
go ahead i know who cares about you
a lot a lot
the opposite of bert maybe a little too
much ethan klein
why too much
he went he
okay
no
okay what are you saying yes okay you
realize what's happening [ __ ] trying
to [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you why did you bring that up [ __ ]
ethan klein because i just saw the
bandit on your neck you're right so [ __ ]
even klein what no he was trying to save
your life no he wasn't it was a trickery
it was tricky
all right and he's done a lot of [ __ ]
bad things right and this last thing you
were unforgivable i was worried about
him
like you hear about stories where like
people had like a bump on their neck or
more you say something if you see
something you say something and it was
on his neck like right here where he he
probably doesn't regularly see it
and i've seen bobby a lot of times and
when it when i saw it it jumped out to
me i said i think it looks i don't
remember it looking like that and i said
bro
you know i'm wor just get it checked out
okay what is it all right so check this
out i mean i have my phone anyway um
so you know oliver
what's a freak
tree trees the tree olive trees right
deep boxed i went to go see it yeah i
did some video some podcasting or
whatever while i was at the um
e3 uh
h3 hey bobby can you get more shots in
at once please of this
maybe you could get one in the middle
here
and uh maybe in the corners as well
thanks
whatever e3 live is the thing you like i
love it
anyone likes blue algae here i mean
frozen blue algae e3 live is the best
okay
look it up e3 live pretty delicious he's
reminding me of meno like just a weird
tangent that makes no sense
we are a lot like people say that
i like very delicious it's like wheat
grass but tastes like no way way better
yeah yeah yeah he's like no idea
all right so anyway e3 left h3 podcast
is a fat jewish [ __ ] named ethan klein
why you have to put that out too he's
losing weight no he's inspired by you
that's what gila said no he's got [ __ ]
did you say that i don't remember saying
that okay interesting
i ain't trying to lose weight though
that's true oh maybe
i think
right after our podcast together you
were on the treadmill and i sent her a
picture oh that's right that's what it
is that's right that's right that's
right yeah
too much care thank you 50 gifted subs
what a legend
i care too much i care too much
[ __ ] evil
milk
evil yeah it's evil titty milk inside
those
tits
anyway i was at the h3 podcast
and he looks at the mole on my neck
and he goes man
that doesn't look good
i go what
he goes that mold dude it's cancerous
geez no no no no no no that's not what i
said i said it looks like you might want
to get that checked out
and i even showed it once again to a b
who has a medical background yes very
qualified and lena's obviously brother
is a very accomplished soccer yeah so
runs
i worked at a medical office for a long
time yeah
and bro i have the text you sent me
because i said i screenshot it and send
it to him
he said ver he said quote i didn't want
to freak bobby out but that [ __ ] looks
cancerous keep green shot at it and send
it to bobby oh god no when me and lena i
was watching this clip yesterday i mean
i was telling her i really hope the
screenshot from a doctor that bobby's
referring to is not what i texted ethan
after this show because i have a strong
feeling
it was but he's being he's being
hyperbolic yeah
i didn't say i said why did you send him
that because i wanted him to go check go
to the doctor i didn't want him kind of
like alarming
well i i i thought i'm glad you respect
my opinion yes i no i i i was i was
genuinely worried i said don't blow me
off go see the [ __ ] go see a
dermatologist i think that's okay but
note for the future
maybe i wouldn't have shared with with a
b he wasn't gonna listen to me otherwise
okay he's an adult
i just want to give him the full context
i'm glad he by the way he got the mole
removed
but it wasn't cancer well i don't know
maybe they didn't get a biopsy yet
depending the biopsy
listen it it was i'm joking around but
it was discolored around it that's what
it looked like it had a ring around it
that was a different color and also it
was like mis-shaped it was shape was
super weird it was big yes dude it was
[ __ ] up if i had some [ __ ] like that
on my neck
and someone's like yo that looked kind
of [ __ ] up but i just
i would want to know i just think
there's a little note you could take
from this situation yeah
i feel like it would be a little bit
like too much like okay chill i will go
to the doctor and i will check but i
don't need
to hear
necessarily exactly the conversation we
had
i i just i really wanted to make sure he
went to the doctor because i really was
worried about him i was editing behind
the scenes by the way he sent me a
picture of him in the doctor office
he goes hey [ __ ] face the most nothing
you [ __ ] face
i said what'd they say i said did it
look weird or anything he said nope
waste of time brother i'll get you back
one day
i said i thought i was saving your life
he said no man it's a jew trick i'm
korean revenge
i said i have kova go easy on me he said
losers get kovit twice
well you only have but we had other
chitchat he's joking by the way he's not
actually mad at me
but let me show you the thing i said
about abc
um
okay here it is
so i said i said quote
i said it's so nice seeing you love i
said see dermatologists because i want
you to live forever okay
okay that and that was good that's what
i said
because i i knew he was just going to
ignore me so i said
abe told me he didn't want to scare you
but he thinks it looks cancerous that
was unnecessary he said are you [ __ ]
serious and then i sent the screenshot
of ab saying oh boy by the way ethan i
didn't want to scare bobby but that 100
looks canceled that's what abe said
verbatim but did you hear i didn't want
to scare bobby he chose not to say
i thought he was dying
i think it's very brave of you ethan
because like you know you don't want
friends that tell you that don't tell
you when you have a booger like sticking
out of your nose you want the friend
that tells you hey yo get that [ __ ] off
your nose i mean i
was genuinely concerned for him i wanted
him to see a doctor
but okay that's it
i just want to let him know that there
was a consensus here yeah
i only failed orgo kim like two times
but just imagine if it was a meeting of
the minds
just imagine if it was cancerous
right then everyone be like i'm a
[ __ ] hero forever i save bobby lee's
life
he owes me his life
okay now he's mad because i
inconvenienced him a little bit overall
i
all i see here is like a tiny note for
you give me notes of improvement yeah so
so what should i have done differently
i'm not a doctor i want one i think
[ __ ] send him like what av said that's
that's
maybe too far but
but but you were doing a good thing got
him there
yes so and there's a chance it's a good
friend thing
there was a chance i was people are
giving me snake emojis now thanks guys
give me the snap treatment
well anyway so
in your defense yeah you had a third
opinion somebody's saying i'm wrong you
asked lena as well
oh he did it and what did lina say lena
is the same thing and again lena is
she's she's also related to a doctor
when nobody's both pre-medical
she has doctors and her family i got
before i went all out and was like bobby
bobby you got to go see a doctor i asked
two other people
with some degree of medical background
and there was a consensus that it looked
like something should get checked out
yeah listen normal people spend four
years pre-med i was in pre-med for eight
years okay so people are disagreeing
with me so
there you go
um people are disagreeing with you yeah
saying that ethan was right to send the
screenshot i guess better be safe than
sorry
instances of people who could have
escaped cancer if they would have just
went sooner that's the thing that's the
thing skin cancer is the easiest [ __ ]
cancer to fix they literally just scrape
it off you and to die from skin cancer
is the saddest thing you could die of
it's so [ __ ] up because it's so easy
to get rid of bro all he [ __ ]
had to do is go down to the
dermatologist which he did
and he's going to complain about it even
though i tried to save his life here he
goes
and i go
really
because you know i live with a nurse you
know me a trained nurse kalylah well i
had looked at the mole before because it
is a big mole but i had done my abcdes
which is you know the criteria for
whether or not i think like a mole is
like abnormal and we did our abs but
yeah you only did it that was the
problem
we missed the other letters
i was afraid to be wrong because i'm not
a doctor okay
anyway
i come home
from that
experience and i let it go you see he
said he let it go
he says i wasn't going to see a
dermatologist now of course it's easy in
hindsight to say ethan was wrong
right
right
but maybe i wasn't
he proceeds to text me
here's a t he goes dude i have a friend
who's a doctor
that's not what i said i read a verbatim
i just said a b
he knows who you are there's a little
bit of an implication there i said i i
said a b i what the [ __ ] what's the
inclination a doctor
i said i said a b told me
he didn't want to scare you
he didn't say a [ __ ] about a doctor
and look at what he texted me so he
screenshot a text from a doctor
and his doctor i don't know who it is he
goes his medical friend goes dude
bobby's neck mole is cancer
okay not quite done [ __ ] that's
how he perceived that that's that's
doctor the [ __ ]
right
and then he keeps calling me that you
got to get you're going to die dude
you're going to get i freak out and i'm
like oh my god i've been wrong all these
years so then i make the appointment for
him too thank you
i go all the way back it took me three
hours to get there because i could go
from insane under there okay first of
all
you know beverly hills it's not three
hours okay even in the cr even in an
apocalyptic traffic situation
right there's no [ __ ] way it's not
even that far it's you know 405 shot
right down to beverly hills stop it
bobby
stop it they do have hospitals in encino
as well i'll point out yeah what do you
have to go to some posh ass
plastic surgeon in beverly hills bobby
what's up
all right it takes me three hours to get
there right and i waited right
and i go to the office you know you know
driving from this area
anyone that doesn't know
la you know i mean to beverly hill on a
trafficking day in a hot summer day is a
nightmare it's not three-year-old right
so but why why'd you gonna have to go to
beverly hills there's plenty of doctors
in encino
bobby
there's a whole ass [ __ ] kaiser
center there
oh we're going to have words on next
week on time really i'm sure
we park
and do the whole [ __ ] thing right so
i go i wait in the lobby you know i mean
i sit i go into the doctor's office i
love him by the way your doctor
and i sit there and he goes what do you
what do you do here for i go i have
cancer on my neck
i've been waiting you know i mean it
looks and it goes nah that's knock out
that's a mole
i got you no because my ethan client at
a doctor and this you know you're ethan
clyde yeah yeah i i explain to you guys
they're make joking oh i i did just stop
the doctor didn't tell you i was making
a a prank on you
no worries bro
yeah yeah i i explain to you guys
they're make joking oh oh stop it
if it was such a joke then why'd you
remove it oh no i go you know what dude
remove it anyway send it to the labs and
i'll get my revenge to that [ __ ] jew
[ __ ] did it hurt yeah because it was a
big mole it hurt he remembered i still
have a band-aid
let's see what the biopsy says i think
he wanted an excuse to remove and you
gave it to him so you're dying for his
there you go cosmetically to move it
yeah that thing was that thing was
pretty gnarly dude so that you're
welcome and also before you start saying
i'm a liar oh i love what you guys did
is this the belly yeah the new setup i
love that i like it hey everybody
yeah i was doing a brady thing earlier
we also need a camera on the
roof yeah overall
everyone that does nothing yeah
howie mandel
yeah exactly
the leprechaun shot
this is awesome how's everybody doing
out there
can everyone give me a thumbs up
love that and now everybody wave
love that and now everybody look to the
left
now look to the right
we looked up
and scream uh
look at that you're almost a duck for
yourself
now look to the left look to the right
put one foot up
anyway
i'm gonna talk i'm gonna have to
confront him on this whole thing
on uh next week
look forward to that
yeah they reached out actually just to
kind of add the balloon invited us on so
i have a feeling he wants to
he wants to confront me revenge
yeah
he said i have evil titty milk
[Laughter]
oh here's the top comment bob love bobby
and the fact that he's a perpetual liar
probably when something like hey you
should get that checked out ethan and
his doctor said i have cancer well
now you guys know everything with all
the receipts truth is a little bit more
in the middle i would say yeah no i was
persistent i was [ __ ] liar dude
so there you go guys
anyway yeah also bobby and kalyala broke
up i don't really know much about it
other than i'm just very sorry to hear
it
they're both lovely people and bobby is
someone that i
care about and i just want him to be
happy you know
whatever whatever's the best for his um
harvest moon island what is that game
harvest
harvest moon what surface starfish
valley yeah whatever i listen i just
harvest moon was it is a similar similar
that's not totally out of the blue yeah
you can just like make
no no no no i just whatever is the best
for a stardew valley farm
that's what i want
it's not easy
it sounds like it's something that's
been a long time coming and
it's sad
but
from what i have seen of them it seems
like they're both
okay with the decision
they're still doing the show together so
maybe i was wrong at first i was like
hell no there's no way that [ __ ] gonna
work out but we'll see maybe maybe i'm
wrong
well we're gonna go talk to them next
week so i'll have lots of questions for
them too get to the bottom of this
anyway let's talk about keemstar now
this is an eight minute or six minute
clip it's i'm trust me it's all good
it's pretty much the reason why i came
on the show i changed my name
wait do we have any theater updates is
he doing okay he's still with a fever
i just want to make sure that
we can hang for a minute
okay
all right
on the show to confront papa gut and
that's the only reason why i came out
why
so
my name is something different if you
want to read that out for me
i was waiting for the moment and the
moment is here
when uh we were on a little chat a
couple months ago i believe you know you
kept bringing up that it was weird that
i 40 years old have a 21 year old
girlfriend and you kept saying that this
is weird this is weird well i think the
bigger thing was i said that it was
weird that you canceled call me carson
for a two year age gap no no you're
changing that's a really interesting
point he brings up call me carson's
whole life got [ __ ] over a two-year
age gap he was like 19 she was 17.
i don't know the exact numbers i think
that's what it was i'm pretty sure that
was i'll look at it and then he's like
he's like
he went on a whole campaign against him
and he's like bro you're 40 dating a 20
year old
i think that's that's a very good point
to bring up there yeah you're changing
the subject you said it was weird
you you were yeah i think it's a little
weird
that i'm weird
now
just the other day this guy on tick-tock
a little irrelevant guy over on
tick-tock was roasting your wife he was
calling her
fat he was calling her unattractive all
this stuff you were getting salty about
it and you were defending your
relationship right you are defending
your wife what is happening you love her
and you think she's beautiful and all
that other stuff okay right are you
weird are you weird for being dating
your wife
this is honestly
the whole premise of his argument is
hard to even
wrap your head around because it makes
so little sense yeah and as a logical
fallacy of argument it's not even a good
one because it's just confusing
yes
a pup this guy pop a gut he said
it's weird that you're 40 years old
dating a 20 year old and the keemstar
said
well
someone called your wife fat and you
defended her
so is that weird so he's conflating
criticizing a relationship for any re or
a person in a relationship defending
your significant other
with dating someone way outside your age
i think um possibly the bandana is on
too tired
and his brain is starting to
eat itself like there wasn't a lot in
there already you know but
it's shrinking in that's a really good
point his brain probably looks like a
raisin at this point yeah with all that
beef jerky and [ __ ] like unprocessed
syrup i mean there's probably all kinds
of gnarly [ __ ] non-processed syrup yeah
um do you have do you have that
screenshot of his room the really good
close-up of his room you got it i also
want to point out keemstar
who once again 40 years old
um he his room looks like a 12 year
old's bedroom
whose mom went on like a weekend getaway
and he didn't force him to clean his
room for two days
this man this is a grown-ass man
with atvs
uh 10 year old fan right away
and his room is kind of embarrassing
um drop it right now yeah it's pretty
interesting if we can pull that up close
if someone it's in discord it says
processing okay there you go
it's where oh chase into the wrong one
sorry hold on one sec
yeah let me get a close-up here for you
guys
uh
waiting for discord says process
processing yep there you go
okay now let's take let's just get let's
just take a nice close look
because we don't usually get a close-up
this far now now this is his bed that's
like a twin bed or something
that looks like a twin bed right that's
a that's a full oh that's
in between like a twin and a queen it's
a teenage science but that's i think i
mean i think it could be a queen you
think so yeah it looks kind of narrow
it's possible that this is like a guest
room
i don't know why is it so dirty then
how's the guest room get so [ __ ] up
now is this water or alcohol on hit the
mantel of his bed that is water
water smart water yeah yeah
smart water and then on his what do we
got here blankets or laundry or
something
also there's an xbox controller on the
top of the bed frame for those long
nights of gaming we're just gonna put it
up above you this isn't a guest room
right he's this is a broom he's spending
a lot of time in
let's see what else we can take a look
at here on the floor we've got
now what is this
do we have any idea what is this
a dead body
legs it looks like a paddle for a boat
what's he got a boat battle on the floor
no it could be it's hard to tell you
know like we're looking at the clouds
and talking about what we see
you won't know how old this [ __ ]
is this dude's got like a projector from
like a
classroom from 1988 he's got a high five
dude
potentially a bong or something here i
don't know
the point is
that
[Music]
if you're a 40 year old man
and you're dating you're not going to
get anyone serious with the room looking
like this
yes maybe a 20 year old he has two
microphones though i want to point that
out
yeah you were tickled by that he's got
the headphone here
and then this
usb microphone usb microphone
professional youtubers use those how old
is this guy again like 35 40.
that's right luffy literally
so which mic do you think he's using why
does that tickle you so much that he's
got two mics well i would i'm more like
i think cam was impressed with the two
mics i like the like glow up
usb mic
i think it looks cool i'm not even gonna
lie no it's sick it's a great switch
this one yeah
it's like a blue yeti mic type
but there you have it
all right thank you for that update we
don't know we like to not miss a thing
here let's continue
are you weird i don't know
i don't want to demean anyone or putting
this is one of these people's podcasts i
don't know who
i don't know i don't think it's like a
huge show i don't believe it's just like
kind of vogue yeah
i don't know
what it is but in the bottom right um
the girl there was one of mine alina's
first supporters oh for real yeah before
we even started i've been seeing her
more and more often so oh shout out who
is that i start us
stardust oh is she like you're you're
like uh
you're you're you're my friend
your god
daughter i haven't kept up with her in a
while so
[Music]
but yeah i think it's just a it's just a
podcast everyone yeah these format
podcasts are pretty common on twitch
okay oh it's a twitch thing
i i mean not literally but yeah i see it
a lot on twitch okay
but there you go keemstar called in to
confront this guy papa gut
i truly believe it's your wife are you
weird no you're not weird i don't
understand
that's your relationship and you get to
pick you want a relationship what are
you talking about yeah the logic of that
is kind of even harder i love it
he he says he says i love how confused
he is
saying i'm weird for being a
four-year-old dating a 20-year-old is
attacking my relationship
in the same way that someone insults
your wife it makes no sense no none
how do these two things how about no i
just want to know how these two things
are linked right so keep you didn't like
you didn't like when someone was judging
you you didn't like when someone was
sitting there saying that your wife was
unattractive your wife was over okay you
like that what's that have to do and
you're like in my eyes she's beautiful
all right so in my in my eyes my this
kid that i'm dating is beautiful if you
see a kid i see a beautiful consenting
woman
like is this weird self-report
where you see a where you see up
she actually looks older in this photo
than
some of the other ones i've seen
definitely father-daughter
bonding time though vibes
can i just say there's a lot of people
giving their opinion in the chat real
quick about stardust i know nothing
about her other than when we first like
started she was supportive of me lena
other than that wait is there something
wrong with him i don't know if some
people are saying some pretty wild stuff
in the chat so that's right i'm not
endorsing her i'm just saying
uh
is she a hater
i don't know i don't know i have not
kept up whatsoever
um
listen you may think my wife is fat and
ugly and you might say that my 15 year
old girlfriend is just a kid i think
she's a beautiful lady and how dare you
attack my relationship
quote woody allen
[Applause]
failing to convert
how these things are still talking
keemstar you're a millionaire and you
only have one 20 year old girlfriend
like i find that i have two but i have
two but one's hidden
dude so by the way i don't know if that
was i think that was meant to be a
ironic comment and then keemstar so
insecure
actually so pathetic yeah perceived it
as a slight and said no i have another
20 year old girlfriend who doesn't want
to be public
yeah so he's running an r kelly type
uh
situation for young girls she's hidden
in his basement that's what i'm saying
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
30 years
baby see you smell you later dude
yeah he got
dude r kelly got the book thrown in his
ass
30 years in prison he got found one
count of racketeering
eight counts of sex trafficking holy
[ __ ]
30 years in prison bro
and also he's being extradited to
illinois where he's getting
he's gonna get tried for additional
crimes
oh wow
so it's not even over for him and also
the guy from cheer
oh yeah that guy he also he got like 12
years i think a guy from cheer who was
talking to minors in dm got 12 years
he's the same thing as james charles
yeah this same thing and he's going to
jail for 12 years dude
would james charles justice win
[Music]
anyway back to this yeah
oh you got to be his 18
oh
aegis is a number baby
that was epic what just happened by the
way how he completely you want to watch
that again yeah i think we should
girlfriends
keemstar you're a millionaire and you
only have one 20 year old girlfriend
like i find that i have two but i have
two but one's hidden
one doesn't want the problem
what do you mean hidden bro do you want
to expand on that they didn't
do we need to know where
is she in trouble in my basement yeah
if we need to call the authorities puts
the lotion in the basket by the way
he keeps saying uh
that brantley is 21.
i think that's just because they very
publicly drink together all the time
that she's definitely not 21. oh you
think she's younger than 20. wait based
on what based on when she graduated high
school
oh do you think he's lying about her i
did he's
i
did a deep dive on the facebook and a
graduation post was posted in 2020. okay
i think what the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] year i think they
said what no it's not wait
20 20. 20 20.
my bad back it up i think
she just had a birthday recently and
that's when they announced publicly that
they're dating is when she turned 21
but it is possible she was held back i
mean i'm not saying anything about her
oh well that's true you shouldn't say
something that absolutely you should say
also i suspect you should you suspect i
suspect that he may be aging her up
slightly to not
appear to be giving alcohol to somebody
under age right i see that's interesting
maybe he was like last week but now
she's 21. so so so she graduated two
years ago how old are you typically when
you graduate high school 18 or seven or
younger right
so that was two years ago
so r kelly does that check out
or 19. i know 19 year olds
[Music]
it's possible she's 21 though it is
possible it's definitely awesome
but
does it seem
that improbable that
it's possible well everything's possible
you know what i'm saying anything's
possible with god i mean either way
they've been together for longer than a
year that would make her
you know i mean true
so although they only started dating
recently all things are possible
okay okay so
i don't think that these two things are
uh
analogous
right i said it was off-handed said it
was a little weird i never said it was
illegal or wrong i think that's a little
different from me engaging with somebody
about like a particular topic and then
instead of them responding to what i
said they decided to go off of my wife
you got mad he he went after your wife
and he said he said bro your wife's ugly
your wife's overweight right sure i love
my wife she's beautiful i don't just
don't i don't see how these situations
are comparable oh my god does he have
brains
that's just what i was thinking to
himself
like no but it's like so removed from
reality it's like it's worked out i mean
it's psychosis he's detached from
reality
maybe
yeah i think he got a brain amoeba from
raw syrup
for the first time since i've worked
here
i i was supposed to pasteurize that [ __ ]
right yeah
i just wrote in the doc i can't explain
this we just have to watch yeah the
first time that's ever happened
yeah i think you're right
it's pretty awesome and i appreciate how
flabbergasted papa gut is too but yeah i
mean what can you even say don't really
understand this it seems like you're
waiting for something that in your head
you don't get it made sense so that you
can have a meltdown on it
it sounds like you were holding on to
that comment for months and then like
this you felt like this was the first
time that you i just thought you were
being hypocritical because you should be
able to date whoever you want did i
swear either way when did i say you
shouldn't be able to date 20 year old
girls said it was weird you said it was
who cares if it's weird i think that
furries are weird
you got mad when that guy intended
your wife is weird your wife had issues
oh my god
stupid ass
so someone said his wife is
ugly
and then someone said a keemstar your
wife is too your girlfriend is too young
for you
odd one problem i think you're you
didn't approve of your wife and you got
real defensive i got a yeah i got upset
because you want to judge other people's
relationships he should be able to judge
your relationship i'm sorry he should be
able to get on tick tock and dunk on
your wife and say that you're a weirdo
for dating your wife right if you're
gonna do that he really thinks he's
doing something right now it's just so
odd
someone says i think keemstar has
cocaine psychosis i've seen it before i
listen i'm no doctor but a lot of people
regard me you know in the medical yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah is that what you see here i got
similar i mean that would explain why
he's so confident yeah it was definitely
i'm not saying cocaine but
i don't know something i have no medical
background at all
a lot of cokeheads and yes that
definitely is
a possibility let's say it's a
possibility yeah
well but he wasn't he wasn't saying i
was a weirdo he was saying that i'm not
a high value man because my wife is
overweight sorry ethan
you may have missed the best part
when he goes like this
oh he drops a bomb right oh it's right
here
yeah i rest my case your honor
my girlfriend's young while your
girlfriend's ugly i rest my cake
you're the only one reveling in this you
sound [ __ ] unhinged right now
i'm sitting here letting you talk i
don't know what else to say keemstar
these things you don't have a
counterpoint
or something it makes no sense there
wasn't an initial point what do you mean
you need a point to make i dare you to
counter that
i'll be like yo
bro
[ __ ] dogs
are cr
i don't know
5g bro 5g is causing covet you have no
counter to that
counter that
you can't
oh yeah watch this
oh
conversation over
an insane point that you brought up
right it's okay let me go judge don't
judge people's relationships if when
people judge your relationship you're
going to be a salty little [ __ ] okay
that's my point
the issue here right
is first of all there's a difference
between saying that you're it's weird to
date younger women versus me attacking
your girlfriend or whatever right that's
the issue so we had a disagreement on a
different completely
we had a disagreement over some
high-value male [ __ ] and instead of
responding to the criticism he just
insulted my wife
that's not the same thing as me saying
it's kind of weird
that you date or that you date like
younger girls but
but but
especially considering like i've
defended the fact that you're not a
predator from like uh
like ethan klein for instance who thinks
that you're like a pedophile for it
which you're not uh
i don't know why apparently papa gut
hates me you didn't say that
that exactly i never said he's a p word
or yeah
i mean not seriously i think you
probably have not not siri i don't think
he's actually a p word okay got it if i
said something like jokingly or
yeah
no you that was never a serious thing i
feel like you make an effort to be like
obviously she's 21 she's your age
or she's over 18. or the insinuation
that he's attracted the kids i mean i
know he's not that it's not really
different from what he's saying it's
just it's weird it's a big gap and we're
always making fun of it yeah which you
acknowledge here yourself you say it's
weird
we are agreeing that it's weird and
making jokes out of it because kim
starts a piece of [ __ ]
but i don't i don't know pop i don't
know i don't know what papa got's
opinion of me is
i talked to him a while ago he said he
was a fan and we had like a nice
conversation we sent him some teddy
fresh and stuff and
i don't know apparently he's
i i don't know it's whatever he can he
can think whatever he wants of me
it's fine
um there's obviously plenty to criticize
me for so i'm not gonna say you can't do
it but that being said i i think that's
not a fair characterization of uh my
stance on younger girls but
but
especially considering like i've
defended the fact that you're not a
predator from like uh
like ethan kline for instance who thinks
that you're like a pedophile for it
which you're not i just it was weird it
was awful i think he's
might be a predator i don't think he's a
p word though
you know what i mean
off-handed why are you taking this so
personally
well i just thought i thought you were
hypocritical when you got all defensible
what people can people can call you
weird for for dating your wife right i
mean you do it to other people
you judge other people's relationships
um
you think papa got supports trisha
paytas i don't know i don't think about
it he's welcome to have whatever opinion
he wants i'm not gonna judge the guy i
just got to defend myself on that one
point there and you know what i mean i'm
not gonna say anything bad about the guy
god bless him okay live your life be be
do your thing
no problem i don't even want to respond
to this
why can't people judge your
relationships
you can judge my relationship but it's
weird that like nobody insulted why
didn't it's all your girlfriend
but you're supporting people like
insulting other people's wives it's
bizarre
i just uh
i don't support him don't don't put
words on my mouth i'm just saying
you're supporting his action
no i'm saying that he should have the
right if you also everybody has the
right right but like
are you saying that there is no age gap
what's that
are you saying that there's no such
thing as an age gap that constitutes
grooming is that your position among
adults a month that's a good ass
question that was a slight question and
then he goes among adults
adults no
well clearly not because you're pushing
the boundary as far as it goes
basically among adults now then what age
gap would you say
what the [ __ ] happening
i would say it happened let it let this
line up
question and go this is good
that we uh we're talking about this is
his own statement i'm trying to get his
back on the conversation because this is
like going on if an adult
if an adult is going after someone under
the age of eight i'm so confused
grooming right so anybody under the age
of 18.
is that grooming
uh
i would say yeah i guess yeah what about
a 16 year old and 18 year old that are
in high
17 year old and a school year old see
that's a good point that was the call me
carson thing right
no
no oh
no
but he's saying no yeah he's saying no
here yeah of course of course that's why
they're left
so i thought that was pretty interesting
didn't you guys yeah
oh yeah yeah
someone said we missed his opening
statement there's more
well anyway i wouldn't even even know
how to find this to be honest well but
but um there's there's uh
there's more
yeah but keemstar is wrapping himself in
some kind of crazy-ass pretzel to defend
this relationship it's weird bro and
like you can't even get mad at people
for saying that it's weird dude
[ __ ]
[Music]
elon musk says he is terminating his
twitter deal yo
who would have ever seen that shocking i
can't believe it breaking news
oh no breaking news
i love that his reason is because we
couldn't verify how many fake accounts
are like this who gives a [ __ ] you're
buying twitter twitter's twitter
[Music]
what is jordan peterson gonna do now i
know
oh he's [ __ ] that's right
damn
it [ __ ] you that's awesome
actually
they should ban elon though
that would be [ __ ] hilarious
[ __ ] elon such a fraud y'all y'all
got you got all got taken for a ride man
time to invest he literally just
liquidized like 12 billion dollars of
tesla stock
pocketed it pretended to buy twitter
with
it so he people didn't panic so tesla
yeah
and that's it
y'all got taken for the ride of a
lifetime dude
time to invest it's awesome
that's awesome
i'm so glad about that though
more conservative tears
what tweet did i violate you [ __ ]
sons of [ __ ]
it was getting funny how they just like
started tagging elin
help help jordan peterson help you on
you guys no they didn't even sign a deal
yet what
jordan he doesn't want to erase this
tweet
delete the hateful tweet in question
you sons of [ __ ]
oh man there's been so many great jordan
peterson edits from that like of
half-life
the g-man [ __ ] so funny
so don't pull any moral stunts on me
because you're irritated about my
opinion
we'll see who cancels who you have that
one zack sexual desire of any sort
up yours cancels who oh yeah yeah
was there no audio
half-life fans
this video he put out is gonna just oh
my god it's just infinite meme ability
wow i can't i can't believe it and like
you were saying on the show that i think
somebody in the chat said like how is
this the same person that we had on the
show and i was like oh my god seriously
how what happened
i did not [ __ ] my dog
well he sounds really stupid in that
video right the last one right he's not
sharp his points are dumb and it's like
really try hard it is trying to sound so
sophisticated and like use big words and
it just comes off like
stupid is that a is that a uh profession
your professional opinion up yours
up your up yours woke moralists
i mean i think he did get some brain
damage from heavy benzo addiction that
is one of the worst drugs
for your mental health it literally
puts holes in your brains yes i mean if
you abuse it heavily it [ __ ]
scrambles your brain yes benzos are very
dangerous and he was doing a lot bear a
lot oh yeah here's a good one
incoming enemy from the rear drop
attitude
[Music]
yes
[Music]
i saw another one where they said this
video feels like when you get called up
by the enemy and like uh command and
conquer right or yes this is totally so
accurate if you played that game yep for
sure
they're like taunting you
pop yours woke moralists we'll see who
cancels who take a benzo and clean your
room you muppet baby [ __ ]
off yours
so i think the benzo thing really [ __ ]
him up
and i think him just being criticized so
much further entrenched him into this
world of like the daily wire and he's
being
he's being enabled by the worst people
and you know uh basically getting
confirmed by the worst people and he's
his sense of normal reality of like any
baseline
opinion that isn't like totally
political or
partisan is just so [ __ ] out of whack
precisely the the people they they
associate with insane i mean once again
his daughter his daughter
is friends with cobra tate okay just to
tell you how [ __ ] warped their world
is
yeah i i saw a cobra kate or tate will
do an interview with uh aiden ross later
this week oh my god some good content
cool
yeah clash of titans man
yeah i don't know what's up people
people really um
people really think cobra's cute and
stuff he's he's it's crazy you know he's
a [ __ ] human trafficker bro
like
he's not cute the man's a lunatic
well people like richard ramirez as well
you know
what is this link you said maybe oh
people on the chat were telling you
about the intro that's his intro okay
good um he needs knowing my name is
keemstar i was born on march 8th 1982.
it was a mild day a little cloudy uh
i was left on the doorsteps of a basket
robbins let me let me say that let me
just preface by saying he's meeting me
on them yeah having long intros but he
kind of just drags it way too long
where's your daddy
he's gonna do it i'm gonna mean a little
bit i wanted to be a clown
grew up on a dairy farm wow didn't
really like doing that [ __ ] got paid
left thank you to go up yours 50 gifted
subs we love that yours up yours woke
more or less
is that true nathan said he oh so sorry
did he grow up on a dairy farm
i think that is true wow that's the
story that's the story he talked about
it on your guys's podcast yeah you can
see oh damn uh nathan said jordan drank
too much apple cider yet that's always a
danger
would do it again
money when i grew up i knew that i
wanted to entertain people
and do business i love that
if you show the stuff he got into
originally like just
i grew up now and you want to entertain
people
alex is a stupid well yeah he actually
he actually addresses that
okay i'll watch this
started off uh right out of high school
being a bill collector
i was really good at it figured out the
whole business aspect why is he
introducing himself like yeah what is
this
ted talking a meeting yeah
yeah abe said he was trying to mock
their long intros or whatever oh but it
was more like their intros of like their
channels and stuff he was kind of if he
would have did it for a second or two
okay but he's trying to be funny yeah
okay
let's see
some halo 3 was talking some [ __ ] told
this dude i was gonna bend his
grandmother over my knee shave her ass
hair roll it up in a blunt make him
smoke it and then i said a derogatory
term
somebody in that game recorded
up on youtube and the next day i went on
xbox live but this is a whole rise and
fall
everybody saw me on youtube i didn't
even know i was going on youtube or how
this even took place they asked me to
make videos i made videos with them
started the first trolling and gaming
entertainment uh content let's get a
look at that
2011 blew up
on the xbox 360. became a self-made
multi-millionaire got a little bored
bought some bitcoin at 7 and 50 cents
was rolling into the goal didn't know
what i was gonna do there was a show on
hbo it was called news right after
addicted to it
so i would pretend online to be like a
news anchor but
i came up with the hashtag drumler and
then one day i decided to make a video
that took off blew off wait if if he was
doing a joke there's no way that's what
i'm saying
he just
went too far with it i mean i mean it's
clear what he's doing at first but not
anymore i don't know yeah doesn't he
doesn't have the capability of reading a
room which we've already learned right
or reading or reading
that's fine
and it was used in a book
that's funny
love that for him
start it friday fortnite minecraft
monday shut up happy punch my new boxing
brand and now i'm here on this show so
things have been going downhill [ __ ]
yes all right not so eridite
uh yeah my name is not so erudite um
well
super cool
so funny how he introduces himself like
my name is keemstar bro your name is not
keemstar your name is daniel you're a 40
year old man and you're not your
basement bro [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
oh so this is a bonus dan loves this one
i'm going to play this for dan
he was on another podcast where he
offered his uh foreign policy yeah
advice
on the russia you know just like last
time with banks when they were
discussing uh
the invasion they were talking about
chernobyl and everything whenever
keemstar gets into international
politics it's
what he top tier yeah top tier um he
apparently he's a russia sim
which we love interesting because he
didn't know the name of chernobyl he
called it uh shariba or something
whatever it's called
the most like logical [ __ ] economic
podcast in the last 10 minutes holy
[ __ ] hell i just realized this is
like no [ __ ] it's like completely
neutral people just giving the [ __ ]
like exact like just giving like facts
and logic here and do you want to know
why
do you not want to know why we're
failing you know we analyze his room is
this the same day i mean it looks
exactly that's what the screen show was
from
policy
is because of our culture
and cancer culture
because if you think about it okay
soon
if you think about it
why do we put all these restrictions on
uh russia uh uh excuse me russia because
they invaded
a sovereign nation ukraine right and
this administration and our country all
together decided we're gonna cancel
russia that's what we did
that is exactly what we did say it's
something different than that you is he
serious or is he doing a bit oh my gosh
as a bed it's not that bad it's just
serious then it's like you know lines
are blurred you know the answer but it's
possible he's just regurgitating some
[ __ ] he heard like glenn beck say this
[ __ ] suffers
you can't because
it comes down to it comes down to cancer
culture all these [ __ ] in
america i'm gonna put a ukraine fred a
flag up in my yard we support ukraine
[ __ ] russia dude
cancel culture is ruining the entire
globe
that's what it is laugh all you want
call it something like your favorite
drink it was cancelled culture
everybody's on twitter roasting putin
like haha
little dick freak all that [ __ ]
keemstars has a lot of sympathy for
putin people call me they'll go on
twitter call me little dick freak
all that [ __ ] guess what
now their currency is going through the
[ __ ] roof good luck
there
yeah honorable mention there
any international um
[Applause]
any international sanctions is cancel
culture there it is
you use the words uh restrictions
restrictions perisha
restrictions on rishi uh famous actually
the biggest cancellation of all time
actually was during world war ii hitler
actually
was the first victim of cancel culture
you know hitler was a bad dude but
this canceled culture is out of control
we should have seen it coming then yeah
i'm basically hitler
although one can argue that hitler was a
big cancel culture guy uh he cancelled
the jews he did cancel the jews right
there's that so all right can you cancel
culture of cancer culture yeah was the
first sjw
keemstar hates the jews
yeah we we need to ask keemstar for his
expert opinion on that
all right well there you have it guys
that's the show pretty much eh
thanks to everyone for watching thanks
for all the gifted subs you guys are
great
tiptoe stream update i guess next
weekend are we doing it next weekend
because this weekend's ace fest right
yeah uh
we could
yeah
also for members behind the scenes i
will be delayed this week just because i
want to get some more footage on
saturday we weren't in the office that
much this week so
that would be good that would be a good
one ace fest bts
yeah that'll be good
so let's try to do it next weekend
if possible okay
yeah
um
so there you have it guys thanks for
watching hope you have a great weekend
um
thanks to our sponsor teddyfresh.com
gentle girls collab which we're all
wearing
[Applause]
let's go
let's go
and uh we'll be here on monday as usual
having fun
let's get re-go
go
go
well have a great weekend guys uh take
care tata see on monday stay good stay
safe don't get covered
yeah seriously and uh
it's not worth it stay indoors man i'm
telling you just it's not working yeah
it's going like crazy right now
the panel everybody give a peace
sign peace
absolute
quest
now ready one two three peace sign
okay one two three salute
one two three peace
you're watching
[Music]
shredder would stop off him off reagan's
acting sweet we'll do the real raw
ritual with more and e.t share a laugh
with the ringer see y'all love jimmy lee
they said we wouldn't come back but you
we always doing rice from the ashes like
the phoenix